You
Sorry, I'm making sure my controller isn't broken. Hello. Hi
No, he's not innocent
You guys need to stop defending him
Stop defending boomi from his actions
I'm very tired
Hi, have you come back over to apologize boomi?
Nope, he tweaked out and ran away
That's one does
I just woke up from a nap. I almost overslept
I don't I can't really test it right now because
What's it called
The game is still finalizing shaders and stuff. I didn't know that was a thing
So
Hi, hello, I'm I'm a little
Tired and low energy today
Shark Week is kicking my butt
Have a little bit of a headache from when I woke up
I don't know maybe it's left too long
I'm fine. I'm just like
Hi Raiders. Hi. Hello
Oh my god
Hello
Hi
Hey she be
I read that as hey she be very haram
Sorry, that's my son in the background
You guys see why I want to get another cat to hope hopefully help with that
Am I doing well otherwise you have fine. I had some Indian food for lunch. It was quite tasty
I have some water next to me
I can't open this okay
This uh this this this shaker cup is like hard to open for some reason
Dude
Why are you doing this when I start streaming?
Oh
And if it doesn't help
Well, it would be it's a foster to adopt if you guys don't know what I'm people are talking about in the chat
I'm considering getting another cat for boomi to have a playmate because fia is
Disabled and rain is older and she doesn't want to play with them
So I was looking into getting another male cat boomi's age and there was this beautiful
Snowshoe ragdoll Siamese mix and his name is Asher
But I want to name him blithe to keep up the
The Elden Ring thing and apparently he's a sweetheart
So I don't think he would be
Influenced by boomi
But it's a possibility it could be a possibility
The cat is not a fit for us
I did send in an email I did uh
Apply to the application form
Um and that's the only reason why I'm giving it a try because I'm not going to adopt
A cat with this current situation if it was a little bit if fia wasn't the way that she was
I would probably just adopt and not foster before I adopt
Um but I want to make sure that uh a cat another another cat can fit into kind of to
Our routine and our lifestyle and be able to match boomi's energy but like be a more level headed one
Um but yeah so yeah he needs a purple officer not a playmate
Uh yeah I am not someone who I get pets and I would just rehouse them
Um
Boomi please um
Even more cat hair yeah he's a he's a longer haired cat I've never had a longer haired
Cat before but it doesn't matter either way short haired cats all the short haired
Cats I owned shed as much as long haired cats
Um sorry he's
Tokyo drifting around the house right now um
Funny as well no don't don't get me wrong reina and fia like boomi
Fia would love to play with boomi I can see the pain in her eyes right now she's right by my feet as she's watching
Boomi zoom around the house um because she can't run with him she can't play with him
And I don't know if that's going to be a consistent thing
Um fia might be paralyzed for the rest of her life so
On that note I am just um coming up with a way for everyone to be happy
Um
And so yeah it's uh
It's a little hard to kind of swallow that possibility
Um
What it is what it is
So I just want to do what's best for everybody
And if that other cat is not a fit then you know I want to make sure that that cat goes to another good home
But there's nothing that like I like fia had her issues quite fast
After I got her um I was already so attached to her at the hip
I wasn't going to just return her to the rescuer I was going to put in the effort to make sure she gets better
Um I didn't say but the last vet appointment
They don't think fia has um the disease that they thought she did so
I will be moving forward with an MRI
And if that doesn't help
Then I will be moving forward with a muscle biopsy to at least document and for future pet owners
Um who may run into this issue because fia is a very special case
Um they have not seen her type of issue before
So I want to make sure it's properly documented
She could have a literally a brand new disease that nobody knows about
Um but she does recover don't get me wrong guys
Like I'm not saying that fia is gonna fucking die she's not dying
Um she's not dying
It's just this it's taking her a long time to get better
So it's hard on me before it took a month
Now it's taking
Now it's taking almost three months
Um fia is my cat fia is one of my three cats
She is a one-year-old simies cat mix with some sort of muscular neuropathy
Where she can't move her body
Um they were pretty sure it was miscellaneous before but now they're not so sure
So yeah um
I'm sorry I just I've been just kind of I've been talking to the vet today about it so it's it's been a kind of a tough day
Uh I apologize if you've come into the raid
Uh and it's more of a somber mood I'm very very sorry I am in a more somber mood today
Um
Yeah and that's I don't really know what else to say about that
Um thank you I appreciate the you know
Oh you don't have to
Guys you don't you you you wait I have like the 3d o going at the same time and there's an echo
Oh my god um you guys like don't donate because I'm telling you this please
Um
Yeah I don't know how much an MRI is gonna cost um I already it's probably gonna be like
So probably a portion of my donathan money will be going to the MRI
Um I already have money saved for the biopsy I've been saving money for that
Biopsy is three thousand dollars
Um I'm a little bit nervous to do that because they would you know it's a legit surgery so they'd have to put her under anesthesia and stuff so
Um
Yeah she will recover it's just taking so much longer
Uh she stretched out her back legs this morning um she can stretch out her front legs but she can't hold herself up she can't stand she can't
Really do a lot of things on her own and I'm fine with like I'm fine with taking care of her she is my baby I do not that does not matter to me
It's more so I see the frustration in her face when I like again she can't
Thank you I appreciate it anonymous anonymous
When she cannot get up and she cannot run with her brother it just it hurts um
Well she's still happy I was I was playing with her this morning I discovered she really likes this mouse silver vine toy so I've been playing with her with that
Just to keep her engaged so she's not bored just laying on the couch and me flipping her over every hour like a little pancake that she is
Um and yeah she's right by my feet right now I bet if I if I gave her a couple pets he'd start purring she's still she's still she's still in good spirits
Um Reina I don't know where Reina went actually she was Reina's been snuggling with me all morning
Because Reina always strength senses when I'm very stressed out um
Boomi as you can hear in the background is spazzing out but it seems like he's fine and settled on the cat tree now I was just looking at him
Uh but yes thank you anonymous um
Yes life back companion um
So a part of me wanting to get another cat is kind of just like
Me wanting to be happy and another part is for Boomi's sake um
And I have enough space I know I I um just want to be my first rodeo adopting a cat
Because I have adopted Boomi and Fia and I would be able to sequester them in my bedroom make sure they're all nice and neat
I have a plethora of dishes and bowls and mats and I have have another litter box so it's it would all be fine
Um yeah and who knows I might not if I get denied for the application
Um I'm not gonna try again for a bit just because um
I know that cat had a look to him I'm just like I feel kinship with this cat just like when I saw Boomi and Fia I was just like
Yeah we're meant to be together
Um but yeah uh sorry I'm yapping because I'm also waiting for black with wukong to download the shaders
Um I think it's done now um it's also just frustrating because um
With what happened with Amy's channel this morning was very disheartening she works really hard and she doesn't deserve to have her channel
Um yanked off the face of the internet over nothing for whatever reason
Uh I don't know why it happens could be AI could be mass reporting
Could be YouTube scrutinizing her because she's now a larger channel
Because like me personally I I I've been I've been getting kind of away with murder in my ASMR streams
And I don't I haven't got like I'll get limited and then I'll appeal and then it's fine
Um but I just I don't know what's up with like Amy's stuff that that would happen
Um I'm strutty's a smart cookie and then she's taking care of it along with the rest of our management
Um it's in their hands uh I don't know the details at all
Uh I don't know if Strani is like talked about it in her stream
Um if she did I bet hopefully she gave some more reassurance I haven't really talked to her today
Uh besides a couple messages in the discord um of me I just literally said the Spongebob inside Spongebob's brain
The office on fire like that one like all the Spongebob's are running around
I'm like what the fuck's going on that was that was that's that was my contribution
Because I just I freak out at stuff um and then again I'm a very emotional person so
She talked at you okay she already reassured you cool nice
50k subs regain a little month yeah
Yeah and so um yeah no Amy knows Amy knows that we're with her I talked with her this morning
We talked about it I gave her a virtual hug um because she it's very stressful
Um just imagine like a good chunk of the work you do is gone because an AI says so
Even though you literally try to bend to the whim of said AI and said company
And still follow and comply with TOS but they remove you anyways it's very disheartening
Um because again she Amy Amy's been a streamer for a while she's also um her PL like
She she knows what she's doing and she knows how things work so it's not like she was
Like me or or I see trying to bait the AI be like ooh come and get me um no it's just um yeah I just
I don't know I just I just leave it up to to strong you
What else was I gonna say I forget
Amy didn't get a strike she got her channel removed and it's funny there was no third strike
Uh Strani told us right off the rip when we first started don't even like
If you like you she's like forget about the warning system this is like literally when we first got into veal or
Uh she's like forget about the warning system it's dog shit like it's not real
She's like people have their channels just taken down no strikes no issues no warnings it doesn't matter
YouTube just does that but so does and then people I know people um are probably like oh why don't you guys just go to twitch
Strani has explained and I've even explained many times why as a corporation as an agency we do not
Operate on twitch it is easier for payout um to do stuff on YouTube from a company standpoint
Uh and just making sure everything is fine the twitch is a little bit a lot more difficult in that
Not that it can't it isn't possible um so like it'd be cool if like Amy gets to stream on there
Or you know or like stream via space I know she'll come up with something to stay connected
That's for sure um but yeah it's twitch is also kind of similar in which they'll just take vtubers down
Um and asmr is also not safe on twitch as well so um but yeah uh thank you thank you guys
Yeah she got she got she got nuked off the face of the interwebs for some stupid reason um but yeah
Oh yeah that's it's just been a it's been a day it's been a day it's been a day for other people it's been a day for me
So I just want to chill and just play some monkey game you know like let's do it um what time is it?
Almost 4.26
What am I doing tomorrow? I don't remember um yeah chill and monkey monkey and chill
They literally banned me off after second strike because of gummy worms
I thought and from my understanding and I could be wrong don't call me on this
The second strike was the gummy worms there was no third strike they just banned her
I am choking on an ice cube within my water return to monkey
Zero strikes precisely that's why I'm like uh and like like I'm I've been fine doing asmr and like and my videos are fine
Minus the fact I'm gonna let you win a little secret
So um me and Strani noticed that my latest asmr video is performing extremely poorly
And uh and not because I believe like my other asmr's got to a certain amount and certain amount of impressions within a certain amount of time
And um Strani was like is it because you're tan now?
And I'm like oh my god you're right I was actually just denied from a rigor I think because of my tan
Um when I was inquiring about 2.0 stuff um a rigor said they don't do my type of model
And I looked at their work and I'm like but you have done that type of model
So maybe it's because I'm tan I don't know
Um so Strani's running a little thing where she's doing a thumbnail test where it's
The thumbnail as me is my pale model thumbnails means my tan model and then like with and without text
Just to see if like that um but like do you guys remember
Corey Kench is still right to this day do you guys remember um there was like a thread on twitter about how twitter suppresses
Like uh like if there's like a black person or a black character in a tweet
But there's a white person it'll automatically save it to the white person I don't know if you got I was dying laughing at that because they put like
10 of the same black person and then one white dude and just focused on the white dude each time and then they made the black dude
And then they made him like but except they made it like they photoshopped him to be pale and then it worked and I was just laughing so hard
And I'm like it's literally like it could be algorithm I'll go I'll go with rhythmic I can't say the word algorithmic I don't know
Or I could be in my fucking head I'm not the type of person to be like it's because I'm black so don't get me wrong
It's not that it's just interesting observation how AI works and what they want to push to you if it's the case it could totally not be the case
It could be in my head of that rigor then maybe the rigor does looked at my model was just like no actually it is like I just don't like the model style
Then that could be the case but you know like I'm just saying
I
Cue the darman
I'm working in the matter moment 99% my mom so my mom came back with with my dad from the beach
I still need to set up the freaking collab with my parents but I'm busy and they're busy
It's my BGM to fucking loud
Just turn that down a smidge um
And my mom came back so much darker than me and I'm like
She's like I'm I'm blacker than my black daughter and I'm like I'm gonna punch you mom I'm gonna literally just like I'm going
I'm going to fight you
I'm like I'm leaving my dad just laugh if you guys don't know
My mom is white my dad is black my dad is very dark skin
My mom is white and I am tan
But I'm very pale because they haven't been outside all summer or the last summer because I'm a freaking closeted neat or whatever the fuck
I don't know I'm a hickamory
And but then I laughed at her because she also kind of had a sunburn so I flicked her in the chest
Because I'm a shitty child and
Yeah, so it was it was funny, but it's like it's also funny because like my model isn't that much tan
If you really look at my model, I'm not
That much tan
And I'm like maybe yeah, so it's just very interesting and I'm like do I make my 2.0 white do I just like
Be like I don't care whoa
It's just like this smart. Yeah, I'm like my headphones and I haven't put them in yet. Let me turn on desktop audio
I think there will be good
Yeah, just have but like then I scold my mother I'm like I haven't been outside you're outside literally every day
She's in her garden. She's going to the beach. She's going on doing stuff. I am in my house all the time
I'm a gamer mom. It's not a phase
And my mom is Portuguese
So like
So that the Portuguese skin becoming in handy
You set up that porch stuff
No
I was going to do it this morning, you know, it's all out my balcony. I'm just staring at it
Oh, thank you. Thank you
Wait, I forgot to say welcome in Portuguese
My mom's not Brazilian Portuguese though. She's Portugal Portuguese
From the Azores he says
I'm going to press class a gamer
I guess it worked for Michael Jackson Michael Jackson had little I go and then he bleached his skin because he was too self-conscious about it
And then he just had an existential crisis because he is was mentally ill and like kids but that that's that's I'm not the same as that
I'm not the same as that
I thought my outfits get screwed. No, no, yeah, no man
That's fine
I can I can
I can do that
If you're new here I can cover up surprise if you didn't know that already and I haven't used my like own models outfits in a while
But I was like I because I like to dress up for you guys
I just couldn't be but I'm like I don't really have anything so I'll usually like get an outfit to match what I'm doing and I'm like I don't
I don't think I have an outfit to match me playing black myth moocom
Unless I like poorly cosplay as like a Chinese mythological person
And I'm like that doesn't seem right. So let me not do that
Although I personally love Chinese mythology in a very dark period in my life. All I did was watch Chinese dramas and they're wonderful
And I think the Chinese language is beautiful
It was very fun watching. What was it called? Hold on. I can't even remember what it was called popular Chinese fantasy drama
It was on Netflix
It was about a lot of these are very similar
And I've seen most a lot of them
Did I watch the last immortal? No
Because a lot of these have to do with like fairies and spirits
Oh my god, this is gonna bother me. It was on Netflix. It was so oh eternal love
No ashes of love. It was ashes of love ashes of love
Oh my god. Hold on. I will
Let me just hold on
Where's my window capture
I
Amazing by the way, let's just amazing cast
Very cool
Highly yes, it's usually it's usually
I
Need to
Journey to the West I like I know literally journey to the West is what wukong is from or like the monkey king and all that stuff
The costumes the costuming in Chinese dramas are so cool
Ow, I just how
Why do I feel like I just got bit by something on my fucking eyebrow out
Hello
Do I like a zit I can't tell how it hurt is like a drama
Yeah, I used to I used to really like k-dramas as well. I haven't really watched any k-dramas in a while though
But I literally was just like sad because I was alone so I like to live I like to live
Superficially through Chinese fantasy characters like their saga like him
She was annoying as hell this character. She was annoying as hell. There was another dude. Oh
My god, he's not in this poster though
He was kind of whiny and annoying I
Can't find where's the other dude. There's another dude. I forget what he think he's like part dragon or some shit
He was cool. He like played a flute or whatever the fuck
him
He was cool
No, it was him. Oh wait. No, this is the same picture just in cut in half
Yeah, I
Also just like look at their beautiful wigs. They're beautiful wigs and hair
You know just like how can I how can I not she be spider? No
No, I don't fucking mites and spiders in my eyebrow. Oh, I haven't showered. No
It's not like that. It's not like that. I it's not like that. I showered a couple days. Wait, what did I shower? I
Showered on Sunday. I showered on Sunday, okay?
All right, let's help her poor I
I
Leave me alone
Wait, what day is it today today's Tuesday? It's only been like three two days
That one small I'm not stinky I'm not pun maybe actually hold on. Oh, yeah
I take that back
You know, it's it's a very interesting
Because
Because so as some of you guys know I did I grew out my armpit hair because I never grew I usually
Always shave like every other day and this time I'm like, you know
I don't feel like shaving let me not shave and I didn't shave for probably like a month my armpits
Because I was just going on natural and I didn't smell or sweat
No armpit hair made me smell less
They made me it made me smell less I didn't sweat as much
Could you braid your hair? No
Remove it then, please
You did smell no no because I would smell my armpits
And it was fine and I noticed I didn't sweat as much now I sweat a lot
I can I literally have sweat stains on my shirt will not sweat stains. It's just like I'm a little wet cuz my
Um
Interesting I should probably take a shower
No, I'm pretty sure and so I'm like
I'm like, does this happen to guys that they sweat less cuz they don't they don't
The armpit hair was hiding my funk. Maybe I don't know
I
My nose wiggles my yeah, yeah, that's me wiggling my nose
Pheromone I'm pheromone maxing. Okay, I
Was listen I was tired and I said I was gonna take a shower, but I just went to sleep
You get sit
One time I woke up cuz my mom my mom always made fun of me cuz I'd sometimes sleeps with my arms above my head
Like I'm about to do like YMCA and I woke up cuz something was tickling me and it was feel licking my armpit
I
Sleep with no shower
Then just makes your sheets funky
I fell asleep on the couch because I like to rotate my sleeping spots like a cat cuz I'm weird
I've been sleeping on my couch for the last two days
Cuz I'm a very comfy couch. She's yeah, she's strong
Fia tries to groom me cuz she knows my stink
Yeah, I'm like I don't know why cats like that so
Yeah
But yeah, I need to I need to rotate my sleeping spots that I should wash my sheets
That's definitely something I should do
especially cuz I just like
This is my cat sleep with me and they track their little gross litter stuff everywhere
It's nice I I or I just ordered to be a little bit more organized like a little a trash can specifically for my cats shit and piss
So I don't have to have it just sitting in my own personal trash can
Sometimes I put that's why I wanted the human dog bed cuz I literally I slept on the human dog bed for literally almost a month
And it was fine and then I moved it to my couch
Don't you I don't use a three-in-one
Why I'm surprised nobody has gotten through their head yet that it's because I'm mentally ill
They haven't showered
Someone asked me earlier. How am I holding up? I could be better
And not it. No, don't get me wrong. I'm not like oh, I want to kill myself. Oh, no, it's not like that
It's more so just like laziness as like some depression can be
um
And so oh, don't worry madam. We know we know you are fucked up. No, I'm not even
It's just like it's so like and it's honestly my fault because I haven't I've just been neglecting my own personal health
By trying to do things that give me serotonin, but they're not doing it
And I just remembered I didn't take my meds for the past two days, so I'm gonna go do that right now
Oh
It's also just I can't stay focused
My friends like it's because you have ADHD and I'm like, but I'm not diagnosed and she's like well
You should probably be on a different medication and get that checked out
But then I missed my psychiatry appointment and then I haven't talked to my therapist still
Yeah, it's been a it's been a time
I accidentally swallowed an ice cube and I was trying to swallow my pill
But hey, I've been worse at one point I didn't leave my house for six months because I had agoraphobia
So I'm doing pretty good. I'd like to say
She be quitting hitting my life
Yeah, it's like it's I could be doing better, but I'm not
No, I wasn't chewing on my pills
Finally, I just popped I just popped a little bit of sertraline a hundred milligrams
That's Zoloft for you normies out there
And that helps me and makes me get out of my house. Otherwise I become so scared. I can't leave
I'm slow, but steady. Yeah, it's like I
don't
I'm in this
And I know I feel like this is like a you're gonna be my therapist for a second. Tell me if I'm wrong. I
Have been told there's a symptom of this like you need you want to do stuff
But you freeze and you just get locked into the cycle procrastination and freezing
But wanting to do something that can't have the motivation to do it
Um, and apparently that's a symptom of ADHD and so I'm like
I've been doing that a lot
No madam get tested. It's how do you feel about that? I feel like I have ADHD
Yes, hey, it's like
Yeah, it's not it's not that's not the only diagnostic criteria
I meet a lot of the criteria for ADHD. I've just never gotten tested for it. My mother never she tested me for autism. I
Think I don't know. I know I'm not autistic
Although my dad would constantly joke that I was because I guess I've told you guys this story before I used to work in human services
where I would help people with adults with
Behavioral issues and mental disabilities and physical disabilities and my dad said it was a ploy all along
For me to be going there
And then I wasn't working and I was actually an attendant
Um
Yeah, I start a lot of stuff. I don't finish I procrastinate a lot. I can't focus
It's hard to self-motivate
Yeah, he cooked I'm afraid I know I am yes, we know you are I'm sorry
Um
Yeah, this is also a possibility because like I I like I have OCD like I have I have this perfectionist state
And I have to have things a certain way although I have the I have the form of OCD called ocpD
which is
obsessive compulsive personality disorder and has a lot to do with control and stuff
um
And then like I have dysthemia. So I've had that since I was a wee a wee lass
And see me as a smiled long-term depression. It comes and goes every few years. I haven't had anything for a few years
I don't feel depressed. I just feel like I don't know what to do with myself
Ah
Yeah, it's how do you get things done?
How do you get things done?
But it's funny because everybody's different because he's like you see strawny strawny is autism
But she is the autism that makes her want to do everything and she can just keep going forever
Excuse me
Did you get a lot of shot? Yeah, my my yeah, my dad definitely did that to me. Um, but I also think
Another reason why I think I might have it is because I'm sure my dad has it
It's different when I observe it in myself versus and I'm exactly like my father
We have so much of the same symptoms
So much it's a miracle my mom can put up with the both of us
um
I don't know how she did it
uh
Yeah, she's a superpower version. So I'm like I'm trying to force myself
to
One and it's funny because when I do something I feel so I have so much relief like I finally
had got just sat the fuck down and
Did all of my affordable housing stuff finally like, uh, I finished it all last week
I contacted everybody. I got all the right things and now I'm just waiting on them to tell me if I'm still missing
anything or not
and weaponized autism
And so like I have my spurts where I but then I get hyper focused and I can't have anything fucking distract like
I like if something distracts me
I'm gonna have a fucking meltdown if I get it interrupted
You know like I like this
Yeah
Uh
You're rude blood for autism
She'd be that slowly really
Like I don't know these and like my dad's the same way like we have to like
If we get interrupted if we get locked in if we get interrupted or if someone
If someone doesn't if we're communicating with someone they don't understand what we're saying and we're repeating ourselves and we're
The way like in our head it makes sense
But to anybody else it doesn't like me
Like I'll have to mediate sometimes between my parents and my mama lilies called me up
And she's like your dad has told me this but I don't really know what he's trying to tell me
And I'm like, oh, I think he's trying to tell you this and she's like
Oh, then why didn't he just say that? I'm like
Because we're meant to leave off like I don't
And that would that would explain a lot for my dad as well because my dad I mean my dad the same person except he's
a dude um
In six four
Inbalt I am not
And like I don't mind that
Yeah
And so like and I hurry what was it? I remember my pl. I like almost started crying
Because my chat on twitch had me do like the online adhd test where it's like the rad's test
And I scored
Hi
For for that's for autism though
Yeah, I hate repeating myself and I'm not going bald. She beats dad for gen three. My dad will be a dealer guys
um
and
It was just like more signs of adhd more like live adhd some signs of autism and I'm like
What?
Why did I score so high? I thought I was gonna score like 50 and I got like 200
Patient is still in denial about hair loss
Um
But yeah
So I should probably I think that would help me and that's why I'm wishing I didn't miss my last psychiatry appointment
Because I don't know how to go about getting tested because my therapy your therapist doesn't test you your therapist is
I just go to my therapist for cognitive behavioral therapy
um
Your psychiatry I have to be tested by a psychologist
so
I also can't adjust to things. I literally have something called adjustment disorder
When I turned 18 I had a mental breakdown because I turned 18 nothing happened. I just numbers
Uh
Isn't that funny
You know what guys I need your help
Uh, I'm gonna make my appointment right now. I'm gonna text my therapist
Tell me to tell me tell me right now to text my therapist and I'll do it
I need your help. I need you to tell this one time. I'm going to let you tell me what to do
Yeah, 56 was hard, but I hit 50. I lost it. Um
Patient needs the test
You're killing me dude. That's hilarious. All right. I'm gonna do it. I'll text you now
I need I sometimes I need something like I need a boost. I need to be reminded
Hi, Cheryl
You
And do you have any sigh
ecology
Contacts
Uh
I am free Thursday
Therapist stream
Uh, I think that would be like a hip of violation if I had my therapist on stream. I've had my same therapist for
Quite some time. She is
Incredible. I talked to her off and on I used to see her like
Several times a week then once a week
Then once every two weeks then once a month and then I kind of like talked to her as needed now
um
So
She's she's she's been great
And it's funny because like your thing like oh, she's just stringing you along to like
So you pay your bills or like so she can just ring money out of you. No
My therapist is so fucking amazing. I haven't had to pair in the last three years
She's like I will figure a way to get it all the insurance
So I know my therapist does have my best interests at heart. She just doesn't do it for money
Um, that's how she she fucking rocks. Um
In the moment when I left my job, I was so anxious
I was so fucking anxious because they provided me insurance so that I could see my therapist
um
And I said, you know, I don't have insurance right now. She said don't even fucking worry about it. Just I'll figure something out
So she's a real one
If if you're someone out there, I like how we like for the first hour of my stream
We're just talking about mental health and I haven't even started the game yet, but let's do it. Um
There are extremely fucking shitty therapists out there. I will tell you that much
I've had a couple in my time that did not give a shit about me
They did just want me for a paycheck. They gas let me whatever the fuck you want to say
they were not girl bossing though
and
Dang those shaders. They're still haven't loaded yet. No, they have loaded. Um
And
It takes a while to find the right one
um
That actually will talk to you help you kind of unravel the mess the knotted yarn that is your mind
Uh, sometimes you need an unbiased opinion from someone that is not your parent your best friend your sibling
a relative
And you just talk at them
And that's why like streaming is almost therapy to me because I can just talk at you guys
And sometimes you talk and then you just realize as you're talking that stuff makes sense and you're like wait
Why the what and then they'll be and then they'll validate you they'll question you more
um
Preclaim yapping is a tradition. It's a standard. Yeah, it's a standard. Yeah, um
You do yeah, you gotta gotta keep dating honestly
Dude
Guys, I just thought of an app idea. Why isn't there a tinder for therapists? Hello?
Copyright copyright tm trademarked my idea
is called
They're a prinder no
Write it down write it down. Was that not better help? No better help sucks better help fucking sucks
Better help is this is a fucking scam
I I recommended better help to one of my friends
And then seeing what they went through on better help. It was a fucking shit show
No
Boomi. Yeah, boomi. Don't take my idea
Hold on. I want to check my that the nobody's messaged me back
Oh
Guys I'm tempted to
Get a garage
Because in my apartment we can get garages
And they have a few
And I might get a garage
Should I get a garage?
Especially for three oh true
I
Could get a garage for three because I live I live in New England it fucking snows like a bitch out here
I would like a garage
Because y'all know I'm not going outside and cleaning off my fucking car by myself
I had my dad come over and do it
Like once okay, it was mostly me. I had him do it once though because I'm like I can't do this
Garage here my garage
With my brand new Lamborghini
She be you barely go out where I can put the car in the garage
You know
Hold on. I'm gonna I'm gonna message her back
Hi
Do you have storage in garages available?
And how much are they? Because if they're like I don't know how much the garages are
I put
No, it's not what I I accidentally typed a funny number for my apartment, which is not what I meant to type
I
One billion dollars because I would be so smart. I could literally just go in the garage and do 3d in there
Because I don't have enough space in my house probably
Um, when I was I was asking the people I'm like, hey if I can't get my affordable housing
Can I just stay in the apartment and just pay normal market rate?
Which is $3,000 by the way. Um, and I can't do that
I I didn't know till afterwards that that's how much it was and um
They were like, no, you'd literally I'd have to move to a different unit within the building
and I'm like
I would
They're like, yeah, because you're affordable like you have the affordable unit like you would have to leave
And
Then you would have I would have to pay like
$3,000
For a one bedroom. I love new england
I know it'll be so weird because I probably like would go to the apartment that I used to live in and like
accidentally like because I usually run on autopilot. I don't think I just go
Um, you know when you like wake up in a place and you're like, how did I get here and you're like, oh, yeah, I drove
I think like that that would be me and so I would just like show up
And just like be trying to get into the apartment and they'll be like, what the fuck are you doing? I'd be like, oh, sorry
I used to live here. Um
Same in the yeah, the west coast and east coast they just suck. That's why I'm like, I should move down south
My family I have family that just moved to georgia
Uh, my grandparents live in florida and I'm just like
The devil went down to georgia. Hello
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. My uncle can play that on the fiddle. I'll tell you that right now
Um, please stop move down south we're full, fuck yeah
Empty bottle the first because autopilot, yeah
And then like I was just like I was thinking I'm like, oh
Like I like new england like I like having all four seasons and I'm like, oh
What if I like move to like Washington state just to cost the country and I'm like, no, that'd be terrible. I would cry
But like they're super expensive over there too like everywhere is expensive
I'm like, oh, what if I like but like Midwest like Colorado or something because I like I like mountains. I like winter
um
And I'm just like yikes
Everything's expensive my rent for a two-bed apartment. I went up to 12
Are you crying about that price because I pay
1600 for a one bedroom apartment and I have like 700 square feet bro
You guys have sort of kind of I should probably do an apartment tour
You guys have sort of kind of seen how small my apartment is. It's all open concept
I like rain
I'm I don't live in the city. I don't like I don't live in a city. I just live in like a town. I don't
Oh, Michigan. Somebody told me Michigan. I had, I had a friend tell me Michigan
I pay. Yeah, exactly. If I didn't have affordable housing, I'd be paying $3,000
But because I get I don't make a lot and I'm under a certain
um
Amount that i make
Uh, that's why I can afford to live on my own otherwise I'd probably have to move back with my parents
um
Thankfully, I make maybe a little bit less than what I did at my last job.
Thanks to you guys, so thank you for keeping me alive.
People are moving to Colorado.
Yeah, one of my family friends who's in the military is going to Colorado.
Because it's so expensive, they moved to the East Coast, now they're moving back to Colorado.
And yeah, New Yorkers, no, it's 700 square feet, not 1700 700.
I can actually probably pull it up.
I can probably pull up the floor plan.
It's probably like 752 square feet.
From Ohio, whole front yard, half garage for that.
See, that sounds delightful.
Texas, no, I couldn't move to Texas.
Because I like, I like seasons, 57 for sheep, literally, though.
Yeah, New York, I could not live in New York.
I have friends from New York.
No, thank you.
No, thanks.
New York's too big.
I'm not really a city gal.
New York, New York City.
Yeah, somebody clocked my accent.
So I just, I don't, it's hard for me to deny that I'm from New England when I talk like this.
And I talk really fucking fast.
Comedy joysy.
Oh, I fit in just fine and jazzy.
Real fine and jazzy.
I'm just going to move into Vermont.
New York is so ghetto right now.
Yeah.
Hey, let's do this.
Where is black myth?
Who called?
Woot.
I'm going to say black myth Wu Tang.
And it's just, that'd be a funny edit.
Why isn't it capturing the game?
Oh.
Why is it just called B1?
That's why, because I'm like, I don't see black myth Wu Kong in the game capture list.
Does that sound good?
Black myth Wu Tang ain't no fuck with.
What?
Excuse me.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
I was, I'm turning off my BGM.
Thank you.
Wait, that's not how that song goes.
You okay?
Hold on.
Let me move myself to the Swide.
I need to, I forget I need to do toggles to like kind of move me to the side.
Wait, what?
Did I mess up my capture?
Oh, I'm like all the way over here for some reason.
Hello.
I just like talking to you guys.
I make a better door than a window.
Rule 34 of Wu Tang.
Grossies are expensive.
I, I don't know.
I don't know.
Wu Tang.
Grossies are expensive.
I think I'm going to bite the bullet and get start getting blue apron or hello fresh
again because that I can do like the two person meal thing and three meals and then I'm good
for the week and it's what like a hundred and something dollars.
I was going to do a hello.
I was going to try to do a hello fresh sponsor.
But then one of my mutuals explained to me like a lot of shit that happened with them.
So for like overseas people, like a hello fresh overseas is not good.
USA is fine, but overseas is not the best Costco.
Yeah.
We're Costco guys.
I don't even have a Costco's near me.
I think I like beaches.
Get it.
Hello fresh is not.
I literally kept hello fresh recipes because I liked them so much and I've still done them.
Like, oh, one of my favorite hello fresh recipes was a biscuit topped chicken pot pie.
So it was like carrots, celery, chicken, you know, herbs, spices, all that little bit of potatoes.
And then you put biscuits on top of it.
What do you mean they don't do that?
They're crazy with free samples.
I remember.
Yeah, we get like a little cheesecake.
Eat those fucking cheesecakes like nobody's business.
How are you doing for you?
You girl.
Oh.
You just sneeze.
You all right?
Hold on.
I'm going to see if I can get Fia some water before I get started.
Because when I tried feeding her before, she didn't want to drink water.
And then I then she went to the bathroom, but then she didn't want to drink water afterwards.
I don't want my baby girl to be dehydrated.
Hello, ma'am.
Would you like some wawa?
You licking your lips.
Oops, I'm still in water on the floor.
When you want some?
Oh, yeah, you do.
See, I knew you were thirsty.
I knew you were thirsty, bitch.
Ugh, bro.
Have I told you guys my tits get in the way of everything?
It's hard to bend over because my boobs are in the way.
I'm squatting down and I literally have to like spread my legs so my boobs can hang in between.
I can't just like crouch normally.
I have to stand like fucking Spider-Man.
I have to squat like Spider-Man about to leap off a building so my boobs can hang between.
I'm tired of this.
How are you going to help with that?
Suffering from success.
It has nothing to do with holding with them.
They just get in the way.
That's why I sleep with my arms up because I can't like sleep with my arms like folded across my chest or like laying down my side.
She thirsty.
This is hurting my back.
There's no weight.
It's not the weight.
It's literally, they're just in the way.
I can't wait to chop these puppies off.
He's kidding.
He's still drinking.
Isn't, well yeah, the back pain is due to the weight, yeah.
My shoulder pain.
In my arthritis.
Children down the spine of harlots everywhere.
You guys act like, it's every time I like mention getting a reduction.
People think I'm literally getting top surgery and just cutting them off.
I'm like, oh, I want a reduction maybe to like, because I'm bigger.
I'm what, like a F?
Yeah, I think I'm F.
And I want to go to like a C and people are like, no.
A C, that's practically nothing.
When C's are like pretty normal size.
Oh, I literally booked, hold on.
I'm going to retweet it right fucking now.
I read, there was this, I like, there was this fucking tweet in my bookmarks of this girl.
I was just laughing at the comments.
I'm going to find it.
I'm going to retweet it right now.
It's going to be on my all.
She'd be in a stuff FW.
And um,
this girl gets a reduction and she still has boom.
And I could see the relief in her body and she looked a lot smaller too.
Cause again, when you have large breasts, they make you look a little bit fatter
because they take away from your waist and I'm going to find it.
I'm going to find it.
I just want you to look at the comments and know that's how I see y'all.
I might have to scroll way, way back.
Cause I bookmark.
Oh, I'm going to, I'm going to retweet this too.
Let me retweet this one.
That seems appropriate.
Oh, there it is.
I'm not going to lie.
I'm literally built like her.
I'm literally built like this girl that I just retweeted.
And I'm like, what I would give.
Oh, what I would give for the second picture, man.
Oh my God.
A fitting top.
Oh.
You know how much shit I got to send back because it doesn't fit my fucking boobs.
Yeah, literally her smile.
She's geeking.
Oh, I haven't looked at the comments in a while.
Oh, there is like some people.
Who just like really went off.
I think all those comments are gone now for some reason.
Or there was like someone highlighting some of the bad comments and that was deleted, I guess.
Cause I was like, I remember that specifically being the top comment.
Donate whatever move to scrawny.
No, it's going straight to my ass, motherfucker.
Yeah, both are hot.
Trust me.
I fucking love my tits so much.
Minus the arthritis in my neck, the permanent bruising on my shoulders, the constant back pain.
My arms falling asleep when I go to bed because my boobs fucking pin the my inner arm and make them go numb and I can't move my arms.
I like being able to wear like certain like outfits because I have big boobs, but a lot of clothes don't fit me.
And I usually have to shop in the plus side section when I'm not plus size and that fucks with my head a lot.
I'm going to un-retweet that.
And like, trust me, like I've gone through the motion.
I lost, I lost cause I thought I could do it with weight.
I lost 50 fucking pounds because I had gained weight during COVID.
And my boobs size didn't change.
I was, yeah, I was, I was like a double D and then I gained weight and I dropped it back and now I'm a G F whatever the fuck.
I don't know.
And every shirt becomes a crop top for me.
You see my model.
That's literally, they're bigger than that.
Oh, excuse me.
People are going to be like, why the fuck is this on my feed?
And like, I did physical therapy and everything.
I've done, I've done a lot of things to like strengthen my back, my shoulders, do all that stuff.
Cause I don't, cause I have a thing with scarring.
The model's in their version.
I have a thing with scarring.
I scar really fucking badly.
I bump into something.
It's a scar.
A bruise for me becomes a scar.
Boomi jumped on my lap and the kind of mist and accidentally scratched me.
It or it's scarred.
Like it sucks.
And so I, I didn't want to get one because I was afraid of how I would scar.
But now I just don't give a shit.
Nobody's looking at my boobies besides me.
If I ever flash my boobies on the internet, I hope you guys would love them anyways.
They'll be like, no, we want to see that's I'm kidding.
That's never happening.
You're never seeing my tits, bro.
I'm so sorry.
You can just unsubscribe now.
I'm a fucking Vtuber.
If you want to, if you want to, if you want to porn star, go to fucking Twitch.
Oh, I'm kidding.
I love those bitches.
Get that back sis.
Swimming pools.
Yeah, sure.
No, just go to, just go to fucking Chatterbait.
Yeah.
This is, this is, see my big mouth gets me in trouble.
Someone's going to clip that, take out a contact and be like, she fucking hates Twitch.
No, no.
All right.
Should we play the game?
I'm just, I'm kind of stalling.
Am I stalling?
The hub is free.
Just find a girl.
Just look up, just look up light skin ebony with curly hair.
Boom.
Just think that's me.
Just picture that as me.
That's what I do when I self-insert.
I'm just like black ebony girl.
I will, you know what?
You know what?
For a donathon reward, I'll drop, I'll drop the porn star that I've been compared to.
IRL.
And you won't be disappointed.
She's very popular.
I'll drop her name.
Stretch goal.
The porn star that looks like she be IRL.
Oh, you got to guess to guess.
It's not Kira Noir.
I wish it was.
She's so fucking hot.
Fuck, I love Kira Noir.
I watch a lot of her shit.
Guys, I'm a coomer.
I'm a coomer.
You guys know this.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Who's the other chick?
Is it, what's her name?
I was about to go in private mode.
I'm like, nobody else is on my fucking computer.
Is that Cecilia Fox or whatever the fuck her name is?
Porn star.
I'm 18 years old.
Cecilia Lyon?
Baddie.
She is like similar hair to me.
Oh, my hair's a little bit.
I'm trying to look like Cecilia Lyon for real, for real, though.
I don't want to make my titties that small, but she's hot as fuck too.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting distracted.
Shout out to my baby girl, Kira.
Kira Perez, let me see.
Nah, she's like Spanish.
She looks like fucking Caliuchi.
What the hell?
She looks like Caliuchi's.
What?
Nah, I look nothing like her.
I'm a little darker than her.
She hot as fuck though.
I'm gonna have to watch her shit.
Mariah Millet?
Hold on.
I'm looking at you.
Images.
Bruh, nah.
Damn, she thick as fuck.
Holy shit.
No, I don't look like that.
Oh, my God.
Doesn't she?
Doesn't she look like Caliuchi's?
She thick as fuck.
Why are you getting fight or flight?
Should I get tier?
Oh, that's a good idea, actually.
Am I allowed to do that though?
I don't know if I would be.
I wonder if there's a copyright for that.
Oh, my God.
Tier list of like porn stars.
I like Kira Noir S.
What's that girl's name?
Sweetie Fox S.
Belle Delphine A.
Cecilia Lyon A.
I get more after you guys type Cali.
Oh, Connie S.
What?
I put Belle Delphine A.
What would you put Belle Delphine S?
Mia Khalifa.
See, I want like,
Mia Khalifa's hot and all,
but the regret she showed,
because she'd barely got paid for any of the stuff that she made.
She shot like videos and a lot of the women,
and that was like in the past and she regrets a lot of it.
So like, I remember I watched an interview about her
and how she gets no money and like all that stuff from her videos.
I just like feel bad.
So I like can't do anything with anything with her in it.
Yeah, she only made like like 10.
Yeah, she only made like 10 K when she should be like a millionaire.
Eva Adams.
Let's look at it.
Oh, yeah, I watched stuff of her in it.
Like milk stuff.
What size are her boobs?
God damn.
Did she get a mojo?
Because like in one photo, she looks smaller.
So she must have gotten a bigger,
which I don't know why people would do that.
She got a butter face though.
I'm fucked.
I'm fucked in the head.
Oh my God.
Sherry DeVille.
Oh, yeah, I've seen stuff with her in it.
I just don't like, I've always, I've never liked her face.
She just looks so whiny.
She has a nice, she's, she's nice to look at though.
Otherwise.
What do you look for?
Sasha Grey's nice.
Yeah, Sasha Grey's a good one.
Got too many tattoos.
I like tattoos.
If tattoos are on the girl or the guy, I don't care.
Because I think, I think tattoos are hot and the right person.
The overdramatic moments.
Sometimes I'll literally just watch stuff on mute.
Carmine Rose.
Ooh, she's pretty.
I'm getting a lot of pictures of flowers.
Yeah.
I think my mom has this flower in her garden, which is funny.
Riley Reed.
You know.
Yeah.
She's, she's Riley, Riley Reed just seems messy.
Lena Plunk.
Yeah.
Tattoos that have flavor.
So I like, you know, like small hands and what Owen Gray, like they're, they're fine for me.
One of my, one of my top favorite flucking videos is, is it, oh, is his name?
Owen Gray.
I don't know.
Is with him and Kira Noir.
Yeah.
Like Johnny sins is okay.
I don't know who Jack Knife or Luke Longling are.
Those are fucking funny names, Jack Knife.
He looks like a typical white boy.
He's, he, he looks like he should be in a background of like a Jack Harlow music video.
Jordy El Nino point.
No, I don't like him.
I don't like him.
He's just so fucking, he acts so weird and stuff, bro.
I like Owen Gray because he's very sensual with the girls that he's with.
And I'm pretty sure like, you know, Kira Noir, Kira Noir is gay.
She likes girls.
I think she said in an interview that the only dude that had ever actually made her like,
what was Owen Gray?
I hate, I'm sorry.
I hate Jordy.
Johnny sins.
Johnny sins is a, is a legends.
So,
Luke Longling.
I don't know who these people are.
Ew.
The thing is like male porn stars are already always fucking ugly.
That's why I usually just watch stuff with girls in it.
Or like POV shit.
I'm just like, cause I like the dude's looks so fucking ugly.
Yeah.
He's, he's ascended past that he's just a meme.
Sweetie Fox is just, she's so hot.
Like, she's just fucking gorgeous.
Or like, I just like some, like, I, I watched some stuff just because the person is just
like, be artistically beautiful.
Their body is just artistically beautiful to me and she's one of those people.
She has a, she just has a nice face.
She's a nice body.
Bell bells.
I don't know who that is.
I can't like listen to like, it's funny cause like I make audios.
I'm, I'm going to tell you guys something funny after this.
I make audios for people, but I can't listen to audios by guys.
It makes me cringe so hard, like really bad, whether it be, and it, and it's funny.
It's only the hardest ones that make me cringe, whether it be like the guy is sub or the guy is dumb.
The guide being dumb makes me cringe so fucking hard.
And I just like, then the sub dude just sounds really fucking whining to me, so I can't listen to this.
However, and she knows this already, by the way, so you don't have to go running over to
Ronnie and telling her this.
But I have consumed before she was a vtuber.
Some of specific audios.
Why am I wheezing?
Sometimes I don't, when I laugh lately, I like wheeze, like there's something in my throat.
Am I, do I have a fucking upper respiratory issue?
I laugh like a smoker lately.
What the fuck?
But yeah, now you guys know she already knows that.
I never wheeze while laughing though, so.
Because girl, like, like, you guys know, most corn is not made for women.
It's made for men's consumption.
So I will usually watch stuff made by women, because women know what other women like.
And she, yeah, which is weird and funny.
It's very, very, if you told me a couple years ago, I would be kind of disturbed.
But, but yeah.
Yeah, and I'm falling asleep to a lot of her audios too.
Just starting to make some good stuff.
I wasn't doing my research.
I didn't know she existed yet.
Whether it be male or female VAs, I can't listen to audios in one sitting.
I have to listen to intervals.
Interesting.
It's been an hour and a half and I haven't started the game.
Even her be practically joined at the hip, essentially, yeah.
She was just like, oh, stop it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, and because I've also, like, consumed flesh.
Posting.
Which was.
Also a little bit weird because she's my boss.
And she was just like Mary, like she didn't.
She just thought it was hilarious and just laughed at me and, you know,
sent a little blush emoji.
It was like, I'm happy you.
I'm happy.
I can't even do a fucking accent right now.
I'm blushing right myself right now.
I am the age.
I, I'm an, I'm HR.
Oh, Vila.
It's me.
Just kidding.
No.
I did see it before she saved me.
For when, when her 20 K popped up on my fucking time line.
I was like, this looks familiar.
I've seen this somewhere before a sense of familiarity with this.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
And I was like, damn, she actually posted that.
Holy crap.
And then I said, I would do it for 20 K.
So I, you know, got myself in a bit of a pickle there.
Did I not?
Well, no, I knew.
I knew.
I just did it when I wasn't looking at Nate.
Like I don't really pay attention to the person's name when I'm scrolling down my,
my alt Twitter.
I'm busy gooning.
Okay.
I do not goon.
I'm massive.
I have to, I have to do that fucking, uh, like copy pasta at some point.
I'll have to read that out loud.
Um.
Yeah.
When you're, when you're, when you grow up as a sheltered, stifled Christian girl.
Only child.
Not that having siblings with anyways.
Um, and, uh, you're alone all the time.
And you can't really do anything because everything is bad.
Cause you're a very good Christian girl.
So you, you, you DJ and secret, you know, any moment.
This is a little lower fit was cat.
No, it was accurate.
Um, the repressionist consequences.
I remember crying, praying to God.
That when the world, when, if the world ever came to the end to please spare me.
I'm so sorry.
I cracked open the nut so many times.
God, please forgive me of my sins.
That's so sad.
Quietly riding my pillow into a oblivion.
Did you think the world would end in 2012?
No.
English, English.
I guess we should play the game, right?
Oh, I keep my game of fucking up.
Now I dress as a nun.
Unfortunately, there are people out there who feel the need to abuse others in the name of religions.
Yeah, exactly.
I wasn't abused.
At least not a lot.
Let's, let's, you know, please read the entire document.
All right.
Okay.
That doesn't edit.
I did get someone did try to groom me, but I was, I was a smart person because I had now had been on the internet for long enough.
I do read fast.
Now I get to groom you guys.
Nope.
Raina.
Are you screaming in the bathroom?
Why is it just a crack?
It's a weird save icon.
Yeah, but that was different.
It's different when you think it's like a cool older boy over the internet versus like an old creepy man who says I really see you as like one of my daughters.
That's terrible.
Yo, come on.
It happens to the best of us.
Haven't you had a little groomage?
Come on.
Don't worry guys.
I went to therapy for that.
It's fine.
Guys, guys, guys, I'm trying to, I'm trying to laugh at it and you guys are pitying me and that's not what I want.
I'm your first groomer.
You're too basic a groom.
That means you were ugly.
No kidding.
I'm kidding.
See, I should be a stand-up comedian.
The screen is black.
I could do amazing crowd work.
Call me Matt Reif.
I'll just be a ms Andrews instead.
I need to shut the fuck up.
I don't know the game is just not there
Comedian you just murder there it is
So men and then the crowd just laughs and I just end the set in this walk-off stage
So how about those men, you know, if it was between a man and a bear I'd pick the bear
Oh, everybody stands and claps and I walk off the stage
Mic draw 1070 Chan is doing her best. Oh, oh
Hello
What's up, I think I think I need to do settings, please
Oh, please graphics
Uh
Okay, it did automatically do do I have to do low
Okay, this is based off of
Am I gonna have to bring out puppy sheebie puppy puppy
Wow
What the shibbity what oh
Those money fucking displays hold on actually
Motion blur, no you want me to fucking die. Let's not have a lot of camera shake
Jesus
They really just want me to
Get so motion sick
Maybe low setting it's fine now for some reason
I do like pet play but you guys don't get that privilege you have mercy for that
Oh
Guys I might have to do
I um, uh, um
What the fricker Rooney
Please don't tell me the game starts right now
What is up with the
Why is the sound in and out
I I did set the language to English don't you worry
I don't
Why isn't doing that
It's on low settings. I don't know why the sound is shit
Wow, this is great. I should just mute the thing then
That's me in the background screaming
Do I fight the guy from sucker punch just kidding that's a samurai
The sound isn't matching up
It's gotta be obs no it's for me too
All I ever wanted was a
It's a big ass dude those high above don't trust me I understand that
And they send you in those knuckleheads to threaten me to obey and the mouth tracking is not there
I understand that too
But what I don't understand
You
What was that fucking tiktok noise?
I want the puppy
I don't know Chinese mythology enough to know what this thing is
But it's pretty sick looking yeah, it was a set of my sins noise
Stay back stupid you make me look bad sorry
He's not just any monkey
He's a monkey of merit a monkey was made Buddha once
No, nothing me can challenge him to a duel the dogs like but I want to fight
Look monkey
I don't make a habit of fighting someone. I've bested before
It's a sound bite. It can't be yes. I fucking know that. It's just funny to see it in fucking black myth wukong
You just say wukong is one of the good monkey, but if I like his little headdress
Certainly take revenge and they will level your mountain nonetheless
How tragic would that be you are one of the court we don't need to resort to violence
How about you bend the knees
Admit the wrongs
And we can put this behind us
What wrongs hold on I'm gonna get rid of my model
All these years
Except for that pig you're the one who talks the tallest tales. Good. I am entertained
I kind of wish I put this in Chinese because I feel like the Chinese dub is better
Wouldn't it be fun if I pull on I'm coming back
I out for my snack and allow you to keep the other two
Because I'd hate to let you miss how I'll slaughter each mongrel of the court
Those below those above and that black mutt of yours
Not only how he said that
They gave you many chances yet you spurned each one am I supposed to fight now
Hold hold hold on there. Oh, please hold on. Please hold on
Can I give me a second
Both sides
Oh
Why where's my food attack
Holy shit, I feel
This car
All right, come on wake up
Grab a push and put on a little makeup
I just gotta go right away then shake up
I do leave the keys up on the table
Would you check what the frick I'm gonna
Why is my webcam
My hi edges is it like under the whole like I'm in discord
Confirm is it gonna pop up now? Nope. Nope. Nope. It's not
I
So I have my own personal vc for stuff like this and so I don't want my manager actually popping in so I'm like I'm streaming don't come in
Like I'm changing don't come in
Come on fuji
I
Sorry, I'm stimming. Oh, it feels nice though
What the fuck
It's not showing up at all. Okay. I'm just gonna remove it and we're just gonna
Get right. Oh, hello. Okay. Finally. Hey, I'm up it
What the shibbity? Oh shabup it shaboopy shaboopy
Uh-oh, please
Erlang
Can I run I can only oh, okay
Bro
Can you just chill for you're very tall
Wait, I don't remember what attack was
Can I start over can I can I can I can I please start over?
I can't how do I walk on
Oh, I figured it out right trigger right right trigger right right trigger
What what does that do
What the frick I I
Get them I guess I just
I'm locked on I don't know
Again, I'm a slut for the spear sort of shit, so
That's actually really cool
Stop stop it's turning me on
I know right sick is a lock on it's still even when I lock on though like I'll be over here and like go to attack
No, like I wasn't doing it. Stop locking me. Fuck
We have laser eyes
That's just not fair. That's just not fair
Is he gonna kill me
I don't know how
How do I block is this blocking?
Oh, I don't think it's blocking when I do that
The gameplay is really fucking cool if only I knew how to what I was doing
What was the second phase hot
I'm a fire in my laser fighting Buddha. Have you any idea how many would give their everything for immortality?
I don't give a shit
He's not wrong
I
How do I
Heavy attack. Oh, holy fricker Rooney
What how did I just go invisible I don't
I
Do it when I do a successful dodge do I get to do that?
Kind of right
Oh
Hello
I I can't really see what's happening. I'm close to death though. Which is neat
Oh
I kind of dodged into that
That's really cool. I'm like honestly just mystified by this and I can't really do anything
I'm fighting mesmer
I don't know what I'm literally just spamming. I have no idea what I'm doing
I
What does this do?
Did he get me he got me
Oh
There's a lot of I can't keep track of what's happening
This is so fucking cool. What? Okay, maybe I will tell my daddy get black
Oh
What's happening are they sealing me? Oh goodbye sound
I'm being sealed away. Where did you get an axe?
I don't want to taste your ass
Oh, shit, you just cut a mountain in half
Oh
Why does the game keep doing that
Oh, he turned into a orb
He is flapping his darnedist. Oh, I I also turned into a bird
Why?
Why can the monkey turn into a bird?
Am I gonna fight as a bird now? What's happening?
Hello
Oh
Man, I wish I had a computer to run this properly
Bird myth
More reason oh cool
I
Like how he's like it's too bright up here. Let's go fight in the forest
Why is that tree shaking
What is going on with that tree? Is that tree supposed to be shaking?
Now this is dragon ball
Ah turned into a rock
How warm is my PC? Oh she toasties
Oh damn
That voice sounds familiar task manager
Okay, I thought so
Oh 97 87% separately they escaped choosing to stay in
76 CPU usage very nice
Yet no one has ever seen them nothing centuries. I don't want to see where the heat is
I'm old now
Venture through all the lands
65% CPU 53 memory 5% disk 2% network 71% GPU among you
There might be one who is destined
One that she'll recover or I might not be able to play this game again until I get a new PC
It's 76 degrees the seat the GPU right now. It's warmer than my house
Wait no, it says 76 degrees Celsius that cannot be right
It does sound like David Attenborough
Is it David Attenborough? It's 76C. What does that mean?
I can't oh I'm frozen
Oh
Mikey I can't untab from steam
It's not letting me
I
Why is it I've like noticed a trend
Why do PCs always die before a donathon? I've seen it in other companies. Is this the PC curse?
It's
Because the Zuras was acting up before her donathon too. Thankfully it was fine. It's for the game is completely frozen
I wanted to play this so bad
Oh
It is I I built this it is seven years old 1070 2700x AMD
Man
I have a 2700x AMD CPU
Bro come on
No, I'm not gonna fucking put a PC on throne
I'll buy that with the donathon. Okay, we're alive
I literally want to cry
Reach
It's a lot of animal people and furries in this game
He sounds exactly like soon
Not the sound being off
I'll make sure you regret this
I just killed these men not men
It wasn't a peach it was the monkey all along
Can you compromise? No guys
I don't want to do I just feel really shitty if I do that
I don't even know what type of build I would do. I'll definitely do a PC. Oh, oh god
I think I was this rb sprint that's it's not rb
I
I can feel the heat by my feet because my PC is right next to my feet
Why she be a muppet because she be fucking struggling
All over my settings to the lowest fucking shit. Oh, hello
Oh
Look how shitty it looks bro. Oh, man
Oh, bro, it looks like fucking shit
Oh
Yeah, we're literally playing a ps3 game
Ray Tracing could be sick or already off
Where do I go is this open world?
You just have me do a whole fucking boss battle and you want to do this all up again
Cold heavy attack to charge
Oh
I can't lock on
What I'm locking on why am I running past you?
Okay
Tutorial part two electric boogaloo
Do I have a
That's where I came from I think
I
I'm already lost
There's some bonds to help the stuttering it's not open world
Is it linear like lies of p yet is I can already tell what was that look at this
When he tips over that's funny
Look on my gara I have a little thing
Like my monkey feet my monkey tail
You know it took me years to realize that
Um
What is this am I falling fucking grace it took me years to realize
That dragon ball was just a retelling of journey to the west
I never put those together
I
Nice I got real tiny piece of gold
He do be some goku
My medium is kind of the point
Yeah, I watch drinkable z
Wait, there's mimics in this game. Don't tell me that
Oh guys
I plucked my hair and it turned into fucking that the hell had my hair turned into incense
This is a skill tree
Who are you a keeper of black wind mountain have long been waiting for your arrival. You look like a potato
Oh, he's spitting image
I'd say
Up ahead is guanyin temple
It's literally roshi
Once it was bustling with worshipers
Before it was ruined by that fire
The beating fight is incredible too bad my pc couldn't run it correctly then the temple was rebuilt
So he was a perv probably
To rebuild a temple
Is guanyin? Oh, I don't know. I feel like I have I'm not super familiar with the lore
Of this, but I feel like I have heard that they didn't make that character female
Which it didn't really matter to me because I didn't know about in the first place
That's a tough one. Good luck to you
Wait
I don't
I don't want to fight furries
It didn't do anything to me. I was trying to gather focus brother
Oh, holy shit, they got you one hit
Say he's back hold what what's portrait to vow what I don't know what it said pound that pup what?
Huh
You guys are some of y'all in the chat are
Fighting furries is why I go to their conventions
Star little free
Forced of wolves and I never guessed
I'm gonna gather focus
Okay, I got some yarn. I didn't mean to press that again
Oh
Hi
Oh, you're a big fella, aren't you?
I'm trying to focus at least I can like do it and run away at the same time
I just wish I could do that in IRL like come on if I I'm just gonna get a nice stick from outside and do that
I
I'm pressing right trigger. I'm pressing it
Ningshi mushroom very good for you actually
I can't see you the camera work is kind of weird
What the hell
Rabbit
Get it follow the rat. Oh never mind. Don't follow the rabbit. Hold on
Is there anything else over here that I need? What's that looks like stuff?
Let's let's do some foraging before we fight the big guy. Yeah
What are you
What are you doing where you were you
He just he disappeared. All right, let's go. I don't know what that was about
It's a harlot
He did tweak a little bit I don't blame him I just killed a bunch of wolves check the stone
What stone just don't there's so many fucking rocks. I don't know what you mean
What the guy ran from
Uh, oh this one
Oh, what the hell I just tried to kill a man can I please interact
I got sconda of form. How is anybody supposed to know that?
How's he bandius?
I'm fine with a little bit of back seating because I don't know what the fuck is happening. I want to kill these rabbits
I thought somebody was knocking at my door and I had a heart attack, but it was my ice maker
Hello, you look like a rhino
Oh use gorge to recover health. I don't need that. Oh, that's pretty neat
Oh
Um
I'm a little
What the hell was that like tricked oh, it's just I'm running
I'm I'm very scared to fight this thing
I it is actually very hard to dodge
Oh, I'm pressing I'm pressing like I'm playing fucking elden ring. That's why I'm fucking up
I might die actually I kind of want to see what happens when I die
I die like a skyrim character. That's what happens
Ah
The rune of death
Literally, I'm fighting like it's elden ring and I'm just like why is I'm pressing our our one and r2
Oh, that's pretty neat
Cool
Where was I going from here? I was going straight right
Is there auto camera because like I don't like that I this happens if I just go to the side
Like I wish it would just automatically center me. Is that a thing?
Oh actually
Oh
How would I want to invert my camera? It just doesn't okay
Yeah
But even so like the camera is very weird
Does it respawn it does respawn dudes
Interesting
Why did you sound like mr. Krabs when he said that?
Sorry, I don't realize how long that takes to charge
What if I do this
I'm trying to do something to you. It's not working
Does this like hurt you?
Oh, but you can like cancel out of it though
Do I like lose my runes do I lose my will to live?
Are you gonna come after me
Oh, you got me
I don't lose anything on death what is a yarn for
Oh
I don't I meant to press our one
Looks like sometimes when you're running it looks like little booty cheeks on his back
Come on, I don't know the controls yet
I
Square I'm pretty sure it's like the lies of me. Oh, I'm not really good at dodging yet
Oh
Music's nice
What the
Magic
Hello
Are you humping him? What are you doing get down from there?
Oh, it's been a while, but the immobilized spell still works like a charm
Why do you have a back scratch? I thought he had like a pipe. It is a back scratcher
Since you hail from mount waguo, it won't hurt to teach you a handy trick
Now here we go
Give me your hand
I
Cool there you go
Should you come across any miscreants?
Just point your finger at them and release this I don't like
You'll be able to hold them in place
But the hand I feel like you should be holding that in the other hands
Sadly mine is like you should be holding it in the hand it belongs. Sorry
It's power will wear off within a few short moments
Though it's good enough against boneheads like this one
Anyway, it probably does. I'd like kind of piss that it looks like fucking shit on my computer
Are you gonna help me teach him a lesson with your new spell
Oh
That didn't do anything
No run away
You good
Reefling raid again. Hello again. Reeflings. We're actually playing the game. It looks like poo poo
Oh
That's actually pretty fucking sick
Oh, the game. Oh, I can't lie the fucking gameplay is sick. I am out of juice
You're so close to death, please let me kill you
I
All right
Hello strongy. Hello. Is this like Sekiro? I have no idea
Probably I got a spark
Hello, good reflings. Wait, why was I rated twice? Was there a memory stream?
Smoshing
Airplane monkey game. It looks like trash because my computer is literally on fire right now trying to run it
You're a member lens
cute
You don't remember reflins
Do you remember being a man by reflins?
double raids
Oh, we watched Austin Powers. Oh, do be to be
My parents said when I was younger that I used there was a person that had a really big mole on their face
And I don't know why my parents ever let me watch the Austin power movie
But I apparently pointed at the person and went mole mole mole mole
I
Was like, I don't know how old I was or maybe I like saw a clip or like they were watching it
And I was like half paying attention as a child. I have to ask my mom about that
Oh, the the the the fembots are always nice. Oh, what I thought the game froze
I'll open up self-advanced to awaken talents level up to gain gain spark. Okay
Sparks will not be lost upon resurrection
Resurrection so that means I do lose something. What do I lose upon resurrection? They're insinuating that I lose something
Get to work totally not posing your own thumb ghosting shortly yippie
Yay
Excited
Do you lose level progression on death? I don't know you lose respect
Um
But hi
What's this form is she be called? Uh, it's called Muppet. I'm Muppet she be
Muppet
Seeking guidance from the deities better to steer your own path what
Chanting scriptures better have to have abilities in hands make that make sense
Oh vigor
I
Focus better. Oh snap. What the hell
Uh
Each talent level slightly increases the health recovery
Focus point a folk. What the frick is a focus point? What's mysticism?
Uh
Neo no, I've seen gameplay of neo
I I did it I couldn't it was boring to me from what I can recall if I'm thinking of the right thing
You lose in one hour I let unsubscribes you're gonna make me cry we're so close to 15k like what like 400 away
Moving around a battle highly versatile best choice for engaging into
Uh
Enable sprinting while charging. Oh, that would be nice. Holy crap
Guys I'm not that cool. I cannot do rise a loop counter flow
This is going to expect me to do combos and I'm gonna be trash at it. I'll tell you that right now
I
Don't think I can do this until I get to a certain level. I'm only on level three
So I can't do pillar stance. What does this even look like? Oh, I'm a snake
The destined one
What the hell
What
I
Can just hang out and wait, I just want to see what this looks like
What
I literally got to give so many props to the dick game devs for doing all of these animations. Holy crap
I can just really just
Oh
He just climbs the fucking stick
Oh, I'm something of cool
Quite a bit of a learning curve
I could see myself getting so caught up in this just like elden ring
But I will be honest with you
I probably will not play this again for a long time until I get a better computer because I want to play this game
And how it's supposed to be I don't want this what looks like a piece of shit
They didn't mo cap them
Yeah
How much is a
Chat make me a list of parts to get nice tummy hurts all of a sudden
Oh my god, my tummy hurts really bad all of a sudden what's happening to me
I'm quite overwhelmed right now
Oh
Yeah, I want to see the pores coming out of Roshi. I'll do the sprinting little chart. Yeah, I don't
That's actually pretty
Hating it with light attack slightly extends though interesting
Herm
Why are the skill trees look like this
So I'm reading no, I don't like Intel I prefer AMD
Oh
Okay, that's good good to know. Oh my god. Sorry. Can I kill a rabbit?
Come here
Who are you?
What was that burp in like HD, I don't know
My tummy hurts all of a sudden. I don't know what's happening
What's up with this fucking frog? Oh he exploded. What the hell? I don't have any gourd
How do I get more gourd
Rose, how do I get more gourd?
Out of you interrupt my chanting hold on I can't look on you for some reason
Oh
Can I rest for drinks probably
I don't know where I'm going
My tummy suddenly horts and I'm sad this game looks like a shit because my pc sucks
I'll get some aged insane
How do I know that it's aged
Isn't it just there
Is this gonna be like Liza P where shit jumps out at me
What the fuck are these bugs
I
Find a grace well, I didn't ask for a new pc
Mostly because I
um
Didn't want to have to
Okay, velour back for buying me a pc my first paycheck
Um for my first few paychecks and I would rather pay and pick a pc myself
Not my fucking game sound, please let this be like a save station because that'd be bomb
Yay grace
It sounds like my singing bowl
Yeah, I want an alien where are you kidding me
Third change
I
Seen a play through that exploded the pc mid fight for the guy because he put on max graphics Jesus
Yeah, maybe we'll do a pc building stream. I'll have to do research. Did that heal me?
I think it did. I don't have any blood around me anymore
Do you guys want me to put it on max settings and see what happens?
Let's just stand right here
Oh
God
I
Looped back around
Oh my god, what's the recommended settings? Oh the medium
I
Doesn't really make a difference and a medium look the same to me as the low
What the hell is this I don't
Like that, but I'm sure that the game would load properly if I
Like it's normal lighting in the night
Why does that happen
I'm
Like the squishy fucking noises under my monkey feet
I
Sorry I was reading what you guys were saying
Like how it's already burnt at the top like it's already been lit. That's very interesting to me
Oh
Reallocate, okay, I'm gonna do that actually
Oh my tummy
Okay, I have three sparks
Oh, that's pretty neat this is pretty cool
I will do that though
It's just what
How much money I have nine hundred and sixty eight will
Crafting weapons that looks like a person
Can I craft my own medicine probably that does look like a sneak head
The pc update will be attacked right off
I'm just walking through the forest
I don't like your back scratcher
So you may follow the fires ahead it's called a cicada by the way
Why did you turn me into a cicada
It might be humble but my shrine is very versatile you'll get
Ew
I don't like that. I don't like how he just uh turned turned into whatever the fuck that was
I don't like my butt
What does rt do oh I can de-transform how do I
At least I look cool as a bug like it doesn't look like shit
Just follow my voice
I don't know why they want to kill them like why they just like a lot of pass through
What the hell
I don't know where the fuck I'm going
How long am I a bug for doesn't really give me any indicators
No, this is awkward another monkey I see why don't you lay down your weapon
What say you it's pretty hot. I can't tell what you are you a dog
Oh
Oh, not mesmer
I'm having ptsd
Whoa
Ow
Why do you ow, can you stop I'm trying to like find out your moveset, bro
What the fuck
I'm on fire I have to stop dropping fucking roll right now. Holy shit
All right
Oh
Shit that's really hard to dodge well actually it's not
I'm on fire
Ow I'm dead
I
His moveset is up alliterating ellemies this girl is on fire
This girl is on fire
Oh
Uh, can you turn me into a bug again?
Can you turn me into a bug I mean to do that
Sir
How do I turn into a bug again
I might have to fucking run past these dudes
Guys help
Do I only get one time to turn into a bug?
Really you haven't seen it come up again, okay, well I'm just gonna fucking
Run past these dudes
Ow
Can I go through water splash splash splash
Our king is really prescient
Leave me alone, I'm doing a boss battle. Well, they fully aggro me in here
Oh
Oh, uh, I'm still going ballad rendering attacks
Why do you keep going
You sent me on fire you motherfucker
Oh
Well, it doesn't matter I lost my bug privileges
I forget that I could immobilize
I
Pretty sick. All right, turn me into a bug
Let's do it. Am I gonna try to take off into into a bug?
Okay
I
Not yeah boy kings. Oh cuz these are mini bosses. Oh
I just like spinning this I'm not gonna lie to you. I can just sit here and just watch him do this all day
It's not a spell thing no
Oh
Bye
I'm sitting in game. It's just really satisfying to watch man
Can I I don't think I can equip it from the inventory maybe I can
I
Let's just conclude it's bugged
Is that like is that a thing in the game like should you be able to fly back each time or maybe there's like
I'll give you this one thing so you can scout and see what to avoid but then otherwise like you're on your own
I'm stuck
Oh wait, you're the kind of
I'm not locked on you. You look like a human. That kind of looks kind of very odd to me
Hold on
Yeah
You got a spark from it. Oh shit
Sorry didn't mean to do that. I pressed uh square
Hit him with the giggle stick. I got the giggle stick
Oh what the fuck oh that's what this is for
Oh
That's cool portraits updated
All right
Wait
Oh
Interesting
Because i'm like why can I do rt for both of these
Okay, I'm starting to understand the UI
Uh, I am having fun. I really love the fight animations. I just I'm just really sad that the game looks like shit
And is running like shit because of my shit computer
I'm trying like I kind of want to explore
I
My tummy horde
That's great. I'm gonna go fight over here though
I keep pressing circle to run
It doesn't look that yeah, but I know it can look better and that makes me sad. I should probably heal
How did you already get me?
I'm scared of you
At least I know I can do this now
Oh dammit
Oh
Just kill me just do it
Yes, yes, I know the magic
How do I turn into a bug then
You with the chinese characters in the chat that I cannot read
Tell me how do I turn into this cater?
Does that guy respawn no
No, oh, I didn't mean to jump off. Uh, it's fine
You know what it worked out swimmingly
Get it swimmingly
Because I am swimming in a river
Hold on pause
We tried asking
Let manifest our voices what?
I was swimming
We have to make the best just try to make the best character
Repent and believe the lord you what?
Okay
Cicada was a one-time thing. Okay
I mean if you believe in reincarnation, you can always roll the dice and hope that you're cicada next time
You love you love this model
You like my model
I'm wondering if this person is serious or not
Stop
I almost miss
Oh
How do you look like fly I don't like that you look like fly
I'm scared
I'm trying to dodge when I ran a stamina
Oh
What what just happened? I'm pressing why
What was that?
Oh, that's pretty fucking cool
Oh, I'm on fire
That's so cool. I'm sorry the mini boss is just like
I feel better about panic rolling. Oh, oh, no, please don't kill me. Please don't kill me. Please don't
Man, I was so I was so I was admiring your form
All right
Can't just say all wolf men look alike
Maybe I will
You gentlemen
Is there a way to be stealthy in this game can I crouch no
Hello, I'm back. Let me just get my stamina back up
And hold it right there
I need to charge that as much as I wanted to
All right, okay
I dodged
Oh, I love how it slow mows that sorry I'm getting so excited
Oh
Hold on I'm healing stop
Oh, that's not fair
If I stand in front of this can you hit me?
No stop it
I didn't mean to press that I'm gonna press this
Oh
Fuck me brother just just killing me I I'm shit at this gameplay so far
I'm in trance by sick monkey moves that's doormomo. I have come to bargain
It's the cake it would be pretty stealthy that's right
I
Yes, I'm being bullied by a strong wolf man
Why can't I turn into a cicada again? That's some bullshit
I have to run over here
Hurrah, what the fuck did that tree just move like that for?
You
See I'm swimming I'm swimming swimming I'm swimming
Swimmingly swimming like that you like that you like oh you like that oh you like you like the jumping
All right sit down
I'm pressing why
Oh my god
Oh, I just realized that's the same move
Okay, he doesn't exactly get stunned by that. Oh my god, please
No
Oh
Samina is very important for the for I realized for this game. Usually I don't give a shit about stamina
I'm so happy I can run and heal at the same time. Thank fucking god
Oh the thing is you'll break my stance
Oh
I'm on fire, please I don't have any stamina to fucking roll
Oh I can do that
Oh, I forgot about that move I pressed I pressed sprint instead of dodge
I'm just gonna let him yeah, I'm on fire
Because the monkey business pretty nice pretty good. Yeah
I thought like I I the thing is
I think I'm hold like I'll hold it to focus, but then I'm not actually focusing personally. I feel like I'm holding it
Like because I'll be like this
And
It'll
Like I'll hold it thinking it's doing them that and then it's not for some reason
That's on me because I'm just not used to it yet
Uh my butt itches, sorry
I try using what the hell is that
I
Serpentine serpentine serpentine
Trouble focusing even in games shut up shut up. That's not nice
Fuck brother
I
Nope move out the way move out the way, bro
Just run just run
Shut up live
Speaking of which like checking emails if I got anything back from that place I didn't
Said
Right so I'll be your guys. I don't know if I'm gonna make it. I'm gonna die
I might die
I
Why does he sound like mr. Krabs for the first two seconds of that line that just weirds me out
Doesn't it how many times I don't fucking know bro shut up
At least this guy can't shoot
No
Oh
Damn it
I'm trying to get out of the way
Happy I healed I can never dodge the second one for some reason
Oh
That move is fucking bitch
All right, well
Spongebob me boy
Thunder scores frost and poison interesting
Oh, I don't need to be here to do that
How I need to do that before I can do that
Oh
I might do that
Let's let's do that
I
Realize I have like my life video
But I'm not even here
I want to beat this fucking dude
I've got a piss
I'll be honest with you. This kind of just makes you want to play Alden ring because I know how to play that game
I like this game a lot though again. I'm just discredits because it looks like shit
Wait
At least I can just kind of run around here. What's over here actually
What the fuck
Excuse me
Oh
I just got killed by a fucking flower
Oh my god, you're telling me there's mimic flowers
Thank god, I don't drop anything
This game is forgiving in that case
I'm stuck
All right, don't touch the flower
What about this one is this one dangerous? No, this one's fine
It's weird I can also sorry I'm really I can hold or I can toggle sprint
With the little with the joystick, but I can also do r1 which is odd
No pressing the wrong button
Oh
I keep walking back into it because the fucking camera
One health and a dream
How did that hit me
One health and a dream boys one health and a dream
All right, I think it's the next one I am feeling good
Let me just not get fucking hit by NPCs so with that
Did you guys see that though like you guys saw that like eight like
Uh, I think it was because it's the flames. Excuse me
Kind of feel it someone's watching me as I'm running around
Oh
Yeah coming out the gate with that
Fuck you with that attack
Oh
Okay
And again I can jump
What
Oh, dammit
Oh
What am I doing oh my god, please
I literally run up to focus and it doesn't fucking focus
I don't understand. I'm pressing the button to focus to do the fucking move
Oh
Sorry anchor him up at moment. She's doing so good. You spoke to you soon, brother
I
Oh fuck
Haha, we both did it to each other
Oh
That's satisfying
Can I have your well
Oh
Thank you very much I saw that said as the feral furry intensifies
Transform into a wolf guai and oh, yes cool
Up in some
Interesting
Rightful chaos tipped four dollars and 20 cents. Thanks. That's my madame. Oh 420 lays it get it
Because he fire
Anyways
Weapons of imps is reduced cleansing them grants ability to briefly take on their forms in combat. Oh
Oh
Transformations continuously consume might might I don't know what that is. Uh, it's like my alt
Okay, all might
Oh
Oh, that's actually really fucking neat
Hell yeah, all right
Is the monkey a wolf now, what does this happen? Let's do
Oh
Fuck that in my controller
All right a little bit anticlimactic
Now everyone knows you're here. Well, they could have thought the other dude do it
Well, then why is this giant bell here then if not to be rang
I don't know what my cat is doing
Please don't lick my toes. Okay. Thank you. You're not licking my toes
Um
Who is making noise behind me?
Boomi
Oh my god, I turn around and boomi just walks out with like something in his mouth and just like stare stops and stares and freezes
Because he's like, oh
What are you doing?
Are you playing with a toy?
Ah, handsome boy
Don't you want to
Oh, he's actually will be older than you. Don't you want a big brother?
Don't you want a brother boomi? Oh, yes, you do want a brother. You want a brother to play with? Yes, you do
Mr. Fatty Fat Fatterton
I'm gonna take a bath. He is gonna give you one. Oh my god, let's homie her
Tommy Hort
I
Just like release the most giant is poop. I just pooped in my chair
What what what are you doing? Do not scare the child. Are you asking me to throw that for you?
Oh
Okay, let me let me throw you the toy
I can't reach it
Okay, I didn't I didn't throw it yet. He just ran away. Okay, go get it
Did you get it?
Boomi bring it back. I know you know how to fetch. Okay. He's not bringing it back. How dare you?
Sorry, I'm just I'm just watching boomi play. Please don't poo in the chair. Come on
Why not
Why you know, don't you ever just you know not feel like
Going to like getting up and then you can just pop a squat v manures and a v allure
And
I'm waiting for him to knock it under the fridge. I gave him a toy this morning and he immediately knocked it under the fridge
Sorry, I'm waiting for the wave of pain to pass
I
Say
I hate being a woman. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow
Wow
I
Is this somebody just like put a gun to my head, please just a little bit
Please
I
Strongest secrets to share what?
Can I expose you for a minute? What do you mean expose me?
Sorry, I was just sitting here with my eyes closed
Dying I've already I've already I've already exposed myself
I'm doing your donathon goals and you came up with her. What's the fuck is torture ASMR?
I mean I'll put it in but what are you planning?
I don't know it was their idea
They wanted me to torture though
Like like medieval torture
I
Feel you so cute. Can I have a kiss I have a kiss
Oh, no kiss do you hate me? Oh, you just want chin scratches
That's a little torture between pals precisely iron maiden. Yeah
Palm a horse
Uh, you want me wait, huh? Did you?
This is my note next to it torture ASMR what is it fuck?
She sent me that on just go
Oh, that's funny
I
Don't know man
Should I put that in my the things I recorded because so like I just had to do the trailer recording for
because you know don't phone trailer like Azura did and
Strani was like, oh pick like
The craziest things for your donathon goals to put in this part and I'm like, okay
And I said like a foot
Rtx foot stomp and stream
And spicy skibs and I couldn't think of anything else
And I I'm like, but I was staring at that torture ASMR and I should like should I say that?
Like is that allowed?
Is that oh, oh, oh, probably
Casually leaves that torture ASMR
I'm like, I don't know. There are some other things I could have said that were pretty messed up on there
like the sassy
showed up
ASMR
I'm like, I can't say that
Torture ASMR for 10k
I
Had to let me send you my note on the please
Hey, man
Very sus and totally above the table ASMR roleplay
What does above the table mean?
Like donathon goal thing was really fun. That's deciding them
Fuck mask off
Everything is on the table the high table
Oh my tummy
Maybe I just shouldn't eat food anymore
I can't tell that I got a fart or I'm having a period grant
I'm gonna put you guys in a high chair. That's what the ASMR
No, that's so fucked up. Holy shit
um, I wish I could just
In hey, I wish I could just filter oxygen with all the little bacteria and particles
I had indian food and normally that plate that place never gets me sick
But my tummy is has been really sensitive lately and I don't know what's wrong. Don't you know how painkillers?
Shawnee, I think I need this shit. I don't think it helped me unless you want to hold my hand while I poop
Oh
Maybe I should just eat more
Do I have a heating pad? No
I had two heating blankets
And rena threw up on the both of them and shorted out the blanket
I'm dying
If you use shit, let me in a discord call keep okay
perfect
Can you can you actually do that for me?
I'm gonna have a big call right now. I'm gonna get in the live open mic
I have to poop
Ah
And just dropped my phone but fia caught it
I'm just happy it didn't land on her face. I just landed beside her in her cat bed
Who else is online?
I think I actually left her computer on
I thought no, that's different. That's like I don't really know how to explain it to you
But it's for your neck
You just throw it in the microwave. It's like beads and that's like essential oils and shit
My mom gave it for me. Um, but it doesn't really help like around
Like there because it you have to heat it up. So oh hi, shawnee
It's his eye the real sheebie
Oh wait, that's not your voice. Uh, hi. I'm sheebie
Hi, I'm sheebie. That's just me
That's just me
Just start to start laughing an absurd amount
I
Uh, oh, what what jokes do you have here? I'll say I'm gonna artwork my refunds
Hold on and again to the character. All right. Uh, I'm gonna go use the bathroom. I'll see you guys
You can leak might hold on let me get your Fuji tech up so people know that you're here
Oh
And I'll turn down the game sound
Sheebie has turned scotch. Yes, I was I was actually scotch this whole time
I have a very interesting ancestry. No, although I am just true
That I am half black and half white the white side of me is scotch. Believe it or not. Oh, no, it would have been funny
If I said the black side is
You know, it's funny my aunt did her ancestry my black aunt and it came back 12 scottish
Fuck yes
Everywhere I'm 25 scottish
So that's interesting
He had 10,000 many
I just started sitting along with you to somehow know it to my blood
Right you go take a job a thank you. I'll start leaking
I'll start leaking
Right from the first agenda because I'm 25 scottish because I'm she be caught in bum, of course
uh
Here I'm with a fuck kind of donathan rewards. Did you come up with together? What in the actual
Fuck, are you playing it?
Torture ASMR, which one of you's requested torture ASMR? I'm reading chat right now
Literally I'm going down so she takes a screenshot
She be she takes a wee screenshot and I'm like marking out stuff that she came up with some of them
I don't understand but I put them in it's like use will know better than me. I was named me. Well, I was fucking one of yes
It was one of yes, right
We've got like a cooking stream. We've got a food stream. Um
I've got one note that's not complete and it says 20 k strong a sub something and I'm like
20 k strong a sub
The ring fit did she be she was going to ring fit?
Stony, please understand that stream was a blur
No, because y'all went to fucking blue site after it probably with the rate some of the stuff
I got a torture ASMR. Where's the other one bath ASMR drunk carry. Okay
Uh, we've got scabs of you being not east together
Uh, we've got a dojin on the cards at one point a one one shot dojin. Um
What other stuff are we got? I've got copy pastas for her to say I got the vaporeon one the boy smell and possibly one more
Copy pasta to turn into a short
But like there is some nice stuff. Don't get me wrong like positive affirmations ASMR. That's just cute like I mean
That's quite Disney and then we have fucking the tango bus ASMR coming and that was a really small goal
2,500 us dollars for the tango bus
all right
Uh, that was one of them that was put in there. I don't know which one of you slid that in but you're getting a spanking for it
Uh, some of them. I didn't understand one of them's called four piece nugget for bummy
Like does she mean actually order makas for the wee cat?
For real. I'm also part scotch. I don't get it. We scotch are a plague upon upon this world. I assure you. Okay
blame she be for prices
Nuggets for like literally chicken nuggets for the cat, right? Okay
because one of them was like roleplay as bummy and core and cosplay as they're so I'll combine that one because I was like
I didn't care what I'm doing here. I'm just having a good time slapping this together
Bath ASMR
Chat goes shopping for booth outfits. Like you're literally gonna be playing. Oh, it's boomy bummy. Sorry, boomy. I know it's boomy
It's just that's how I read it. All right. Fuck it. Who said short ASMR?
Which one of you because you know who's gonna have to write it if she be doesn't have time to write it me
All right, I'm gonna be kicked out of Australia because one of the harem members were like
Mmm, can what I fancy get in my pickle diddles right that it was you?
Harem sick. Um
get him
Get that man
Get that man. He knows what he wants
So if I get kicked out of scotland because your little penis
Was typing on the keyboard out of scotland out of australia back to scotland. You're getting it
You're getting sick on
Do not get kicked out of australia
No, because emmy and acy aren't in australia. Are they?
No, so I cannot be kicked out for that. I'm gonna be kicked out for what I do in here, though
Please
Uh, I also have ASMR of she be and her mom
She be and her mom are going to be doing ASMR
I couldn't even imagine looking my mom in the eyes on the other side of the microphone being like it ain't mohen
This is what you have to do
she be's mom
ASMR
Fucking hell
Fuck yeah, the universe is expanding forget she be elizabeth sin third something something like
Her mom's gonna be in an ASMR. I'm pimping out her mom
Harem you have made me pimp out the mother of one of my talents
Do you not understand that your actions have consequences your suggestions have consequences your feedback?
consequences
What have you done?
Not your own rules
Eh, I'll go with the public audio scenarios
Ask each little dj to friends
I think she's getting a new pc a third pc and one of the goals
But she meant to make sure we opened a new pc and one of the other
I'll do everything
It's so touching and I'm like, oh, sorry that came too strong
No, by the way, hello
Her internet person
Eh
She is
It's like
One dollar reward we upgrade she bees in her necks with the fuck is this?
Bruh
Shocking behavior fucking on dial up
Feature burst candy be on dial up. That's it. You're getting a spanking
She needs the ethernet. Is she not got an ethernet cable? Maybe her ethernet cable is old
I've got an office siren voice pack public release. That'll be interesting. Um
She's gonna do two sleep aid audios. That's very cute. Now before anyone's like what you're actually leaking her
No, this is the stuff she sent me that she already came together with you
Dial up phone feature for gen three real
Eh, we have a bra reveal
Uh, all of the alert is going to show their little yeti's
No, not the yeti's part the thing that covers the yeti's we're not going to show our yeti's that's not going to be company mandated
Okay, so i'm going to be company man bait man. No, she uses wi-fi
You don't use an ethernet cable. I I have gigabit internet, but I use wi-fi
Are you trolling? I'll literally cut out while she would away taking my phone
I heard it. I was listening to you while I was
And you're just like
He's not like a scottish robot. I was dying. I'm talking right you see right
I'm going to send you a link, okay, and I'm going to make you watch this
Not only sheby's going to have access to this link
And the reason why sheby's going to have access to actually I'm watching real time
I am changing the 50 dollar reward of chat tweets chat picks a tweet
sheby
Oh, fuck. I can't edit it because I'm on the wrong fucking account. Shit. Right. Okay. Nice job
I know literally the one dollar. I'm gonna you know what? I'm gonna create a one dollar reward
And it says sheby plugs in the ethernet cable
That's it. That's the reward. I don't have an ethernet cable
Oh my
Right. Okay. We will we will deal with it when it happens. But as you can see
If you want to scan that I'm getting rather close to finishing
A few things probably need swapped around great. I have to draw. Fuck
No, I like your doodles. They're so cute. Okay
I really liked your donut on doodles. I think they were sweet. Um
Maybe my debut
Yeah, wait, what did I say? You said my donut on doodles. I feel it. It both begin with D. It's the same word at the end of the day. Uh
I suggest I need to change the sugar baby voice pack. That's not yours. And yeah, because I'm like, wait, wasn't that a Zerz?
No, no, no. I took a Zerz one and changed everything to you.
Eat a Cricut
I was like, I'll actually put ooo next to eat a Cricut E
delicious
Vichyver agency evil Vichyver agency makes talent eat
Cockroaches. Oh god
No, I'm not gonna make you eat cockroaches. I'll make you eat a Cricut. That's funny
Did I miss another donut on? No, she visas next on the 28th. What is re you just put recreate?
Where are oh no
One of my recreating I'm scared
What number
Oh
No, no, look on the bottom you sent me. Oh, I didn't see the pages come up
Recreate that's a uh
Yeah, and your note you sent me from your
Sananigans with a hero. Um you put
A strongy 20k something, but I can't physically physically I can't like see the end of it
It just says maybe like I was saying oh because I was gonna yeah, I was gonna
recreate your 20k photo
Oh, you're oh
I mean, oh no
Maybe recreate strongy 20k sub
Photo it's supposed to say photo
Yeah, I couldn't say I was like 20k something. I don't know. Okay, we're gonna hear him, but
I want to see that slay new pc
I don't I had no idea so I said for for that number
Because I knew you can't have mentioned one a new pc and I'm like, well that seems like the the plausible thing
Sorry, I'm so sorry to hear him. That's listening in right now. This is basically how I communicate to she be. I'm like, um, yes. Yeah, so
That's fine. Yeah
I can never spell karaoke for my life
That's true
We should
That should be your middle name
Karaoke because then then you like sing to them
It's just a misspelling of karaoke
strongy kariokes
cuttles
Karaoke cuttles coming at you live through them
Cat they okay
Right, I'm gonna let you get back to it
I'm gonna finish this up and then I'll spank you with a few more
Things and then I'll let you know that the trailer is being sent off and we can have all fun times
Carry only cuttles, uh, okay, this looks nice
Cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool cool
Sorry, I'm reading through the entire thing
Oh, no
Okay, okay, sorry, I'm um
I'm I'm
I'm looking at something so I'm gonna be doing something a little bit different
Then uh, I'll I'll order the ethernet cable right now. Here's my phone. Uh, I need I need a long cord
I don't know how I'm gonna fucking run it because it's on my closet on the other side side of the room
um
So I'll have to like get pins and shit for it to pin it into place
Um
I think yeah, I think like a 50 foot cable would be fine
I'll do that right now
Amazon
um
So I'm doing something a little bit different
than a Zura
Azura's thing
I'm adding a punishment wheel and the punishments the straw me put
Oh my god, she wants me to die
Yeah, I'm gonna do the flat cable amazon. Why did you crash? Hello?
All right
Flat ethernet cable 50 feet
Does it come with stuff?
What is the difference between 40 gb gbps versus cat 6 10 gbps that says cat 8
I'm assuming I want the cat 8 one
Cat 8 40 gigabytes per second
Speed I am speed I probably a 30 foot one would be fine actually
Um, does it come with little thingies does it come with little pins
I had them at my parents house when I lived there. Does it come with it?
Snagless design
No, it doesn't come with it
Wait does it I can't fucking tell bro
Stop posting fucking pictures and just tell me if it comes with the little things to stick it to the wall
Because my cats will fucking bite it. That's another reason why I don't have those cables
This one doesn't have it
Nobody's telling me if it's coming with uh, can I get like
Oh, it does come with clips. Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Bye now
Ooh five percent coupon by now
Place order
All right, give me 20 bucks. No, I'm kidding
All right, uh
Honestly, I haven't looked at my ioboard in the longest time. I I think there's an ethernet block
It definitely comes with that yet
I
Double in and pass it on
Okay, let's keep playing
I've been um
I've been okay. Hold on. Let me just
I've been sleeping a lot as one does
I
Was kidding you fuck
God damn it
And the guys
Stop
Okay, thanks
Thank you so much stash and anonymous. You guys are
fucking goober's
Chads I wish I could can I like refund it?
Can I refund people is that a thing I can do?
Nope, it just brings me to your channel
You have videos up from 13 years ago
I
I'm sorry
And I tapped on the thing that don't know what it brought me to your channel
That's funny
Why are you I snoop I'm gonna snoop on you guys right now go to channel
Why you have kingdom hearts playlists
Let's see let's see
This channel doesn't have any content fuck you
Perverse fandom I give you your money back
It's hard to do this without like actually I can oh it does automatically open that
You made a skate simulation video, okay
Nothing goes on this account
Why are you guys boring I stalk your guys's um
Twitter's too sometimes you guys like
Reply to one of my tweets and I'm like let me just look through your things real quick
What what have you retweeted?
Maybe I'll have maybe part of my donut phone. I'll watch her
Anonymous tip four dollars and twenty cents something something free money EZ
You're a dork. Thank you anonymous
Why do you have a I sometimes you're you guys profile pictures up close are a little bit scary
Hello
Nothing
again, you guys are on your alts because you come over here and you
You you treat us like your little side whores, which if I'm your side whore if you're not on your main account
And I'm your side whore you don't love me you don't love me
Become osha certified. Oh, this is destiny videos like you said
Yeah, but sometimes you guys forget
Like you have a profile picture on fire. I also just haven't seen you guys's profile pictures up close
Why did you change your name?
Your name is different. I almost didn't recognize you
What the hell
What the hell is your profile that doesn't make any sense
Imagine hiding your main let's check your account then
I
Cute picture of you and I see
I'm creeping on your guys's profile pictures and channels right now
What is that? What is that? It's a hawk
I'm doing devil horns. That's so weird
Imagine having alts
Hmm you have an alien profile picture
Because you can't tell like on like you guys are so small. I can't see your little your little thing
I
Know some of you guys change your names and change your accounts so you can you don't make your other oh she feels sad
Yeah, I know how it is you man whores
Fuck all of you
Six months ago you recorded the changing of the english guard
Got some overwatch
Clips you got some blaze blue clips. What else you got on here?
I don't know what this game is. What is suko yomi?
You guys you need to do a better job
Eight years ago. You needed to do a better job eight years ago of naming your videos, buddy
I am your oh she I doubt it
I bet you guys talk about other women all the time
I bet you don't really love the alert girls
I'm gonna be a jealous girlfriend right now. I'm looking through all your stuff to make sure you're not cheating on me
Other oh she
This ai
What game is this?
Got some league disgusting. No bushi versus tiondi
Some disgusting league gameplay
You
Have some fish
I'm gonna draw my picture and change my username. Oh, yeah
What is this picture of vegeta, what I never noticed that that was your fucking profile picture
Let's see
Oh, chill. What is scrawny draw for you?
sukoi desu ne
Nihongo horny doem
What name is that?
It's for honor
Oh
You got hold on you got your graduation. I'll watch your graduation video
Let's do that right now. I'm gonna I'll meet the meet the desktop
Oh
Look at you walking across the stage. What is this college or
High school nice little bow. Wow. Look at you and your gown. You get him tiger
Someone just took a gigantic flash of a photo
Good job. Good graduation. Very proud of you 2015
Who's graduating is k graduated nine years ago
Now I know what you look like
You're next come here stops everybody stop talking so I can okay. I got the channel
Uh go to channel
You have a black mithukong thing
Why is it heavenly music when there's no music on there?
Do you know chinese you have chinese characters in your name? No japanese
Chinese japanese japanese chinese
Sometimes it's hard for me to tell in the youtube chat
I can't believe you're graduating
Uh
Perfect you're next. I'm trying to click on people's names that
How do you have no content but you have 95 subscribers. What are you hiding?
And you're creepily like holding a milk bottle. What?
Don't turn out the lights
Six years ago did you wait did you re upload? Is this a cover? Hold on. Let's do this
What is this bro?
Did you literally just re upload of somebody's music?
Is it yeah
Especially because it's on stream don't worry guys aren't gonna have any I the desktop audience
And I don't have any window sharing on
You can't hide from me
You don't even have anything on your channel I already checked it
Okay, everybody who's talking has already been called out so I guess you're all safe now
Oh
That's what that is
Slow torture. Yeah seems you guys like privated stuff
Oh, nope, you're not safe. You're no longer safe. You should have never spoken. Give me your name
Go to channel
nothing
wait
Dragon ball gt and guitar
There's an ad on your video 14 years ago. Y'all are old
Oh
Have you improved your guitar playing you play better than I do I can't play at all, but this is pretty bad
I
This is fun
Gonk plays tower defense. Ooh 216 views very good
Team killing boomers and mwo to trick them into reading out the entire d tdk our opening scene
And then I think you clicked a vtuber
Let's see the vtuber clip
What is your favorite tag kupa fortuna
That's a funny tag um
Oh, yeah, you guys are very lucky that there's hidden likes I'll tell you that much
Because I would be going through your stuff all the time
Why is your last name gay?
The one that sucks for you
With your little emo anime boy profile picture
No, his little no his last name is literally gay. I don't know what to tell you it says his name the gay. I don't
Just sucks for him
Why are you gay?
Why are you being so gay?
Is that a good emmy impression?
Not cool. Oh cry harder
um
Let me see. Oh perfect
There you are get over here
Give me food that's a cute profile picture. I don't know who that person is
Weave music nice nice playlist. Why do you why do you put your crunchy roll in your
Why did you put your crunchy roll in there?
You put your crunchy roll link. Is that your is that your referral link? You just stuck it in your youtube?
Huh
Wait, oh there's more new people. Oh perfect. Oh
Nope, you have absolutely nothing boring. What about you come here
It's me just picture me grabbing your face and just staring into your eyes. What is your profile picture?
That looks like a fucked up animal crossing character
You
Oh what you made highlights of me
Oh, wait. Yes, I do recall seeing this two months ago and then you made a highlight of mercena zura
That's cute
adorable
It's like facing a firing squad except it's I bet you I bet you guys didn't expect to be
So feel so personally attacked by your the person that you watch
Can't resist or more of some more transistor
Twisted transistor
Let's see
Never mind that's just ignore that
Looks like you stream yourself
I'm gonna watch your Hades gameplay
You
Take more damage than punch more
Oh, well, I'm getting spoilers. I'm getting spoilers
Go back. I'll watch you fight magura
Damn you finish that run to get to the snow place really fucking fast Jesus
Nice nice nice nice magara kill
Magura whatever that's how you pronounce it
Uh, wait, I saw him new more new people. Let me scroll up
You've been a bad boy. Have you now let me take a peek. There's nothing there you with your one subscriber
This is fun
Now I can spot expose you guys in the open
Oh, you're back. You fell asleep. Oh, you came back at the most perfect time
Me playing hell diver two is a lot of fun. Oh, let's watch it
Let's watch
You
What is this includes paid promotion you have a very amusing voice
Um
Let's see anybody else wait
Alien Romulus review. Oh
You're very well spoken
I
Recommend changing your lighting because you're a little bit yellow
I feel like I think you can do some color grading there and then you want to make sure you clean up your background a little bit
And you want to go by the rule of fourths when you're shooting something just like in a photo like when it like grid
And you gotta you want it you want to make yourself a little bit higher because your your your chair is a little bit taller than you
I'm giving feet. I'm just recommending stuff. I used to make video cam videos with a lot of face cam. I don't sell you
Do you do this in one take
Holy shit, you did did you do this in one take? I can't really tell I'm not watching the whole thing. Um
Paying you not to remember a pro. No, I am they're burned into my memory
Hello new person. Uh, let me look at your stuff caterpillar picnic shortstop motion
Oh my god, this is so cute
Your stop motion is very adorable. Oh my god, he just ate a giant cupcake
That's pretty sick. Yes, I'm a rabbit muppet. Hello
Yeah, I'm going through your stuff to make sure you're not cheating on me. Um, let's see
Unless you're oh, she decides to bully you. Oh, you made a new account. Oh, so you hate me then
You hate me. You must hate me if you made a new account just to be with me. Wow
What happened to emmy her channel got terminated bro, I'm so sorry
She's terminally ill
But just like imagine like picture me saying she's terminally ill, but then like a giant awesome guitar bass riff like
Like that
Uh, don't worry. We're working on reinstating her channel. I don't know why you'd ask me though. It's not like I can do anything
All right, let's check out your stuff
Gang beast episode five your most recent but any of what is this hell of a boss? I don't know. Uh
Five years ago, let's take a listen
Very 90s opening editing the music is extremely loud
The music is extremely loud
It's house music
There's no dialogue
It's just it's really just gang beast with house slash dub stuff in the background. All right
Um
Yeah, fake harlot, what are you doing here? Hand it over hand over your original account right now. I'm going through your stuff
I
Do you like house music? I think it was house music. I know it was idiom
Um
Come on you guys are keeping me entertained
Give me more stuff to look at
more people new people talk
lurkers
Could I could I look at your channel already?
Oh, I did it fortnight walmart prop hunt full session. All right, let's take a peek
They have prop night prop night they have prop hunt in fortnight
Okay
My brother in christ your friend doesn't echo
I don't know if these are people they just got randomly spawned in with
You
Did you did you stream this or did you just upload it?
Some kid just fucking burps so loud
Yeah
Everybody's so echoey I can't just an archive
Well, one of those people needs to go through puberty
Don't go through twitters. I can't go to your twitters from youtube
um
Unless your twitter is the same as your name
Then I've probably already gone through your twitter already
You know what let's just I think I'm down with black myth will call
How do I get out of here?
I hope it's saved. I don't know if it did
Oh my god, I just threw up in my mouth
Oh
I'm booting up live 2g
Bye monkey. Yep, you know me. I only play like two seconds of a game
Two seconds of a game
Oh my god
Hello, I look so fucking creepy
Gave muppets. No muppet shebe's gone. Sorry. She's not here right now. You have me. I'm kind of a muppet. I can do this
I
Does that keep you entertained?
I'm sort of nice there. Wait, hold on. Did I look at your? No, yeah, I did look at your account
Damn it. My lurkers are being extra quiet. Oh, hello, you're new
He he he he
Oh, you just have playlists. Oh, you like gorillas though fabulous
Chantio empiedra party too
All right, I guess I guess you you pass
Can you jingle some keys? No, but I can look at your channel and see what you have on there nothing you just have an emo girl picture
Oh
You
Hello, you you've been lurking today and being pretty quiet
What is this from devil man crybaby? What is that?
Wait, you made something 12 years ago with 46k views
Oh
It's because you re-uploaded a scene from an anime and a high quality
Yeah, that's pretty nice
Unless you go in here you got some buying craft. No, what's a rocket jumping? What why do you so many views?
You 8k views on you
Doing some sort of
Wait, is this like surf?
Except you're fucking jumping with rockets
What is this roblox?
What game is this
Don't look I'm sorry. I'm looking at you. I've never heard ever rocket jumping of this game. It literally looks like surf
I'm at my direction
video of anime edited to the beat of a song
1k views 13 years ago
I
What song is this
That's from elfin light have faith in me a day to remember
Oh, um, she's nakey. How's this video so up?
What is this in our x hold on i'm gonna read you out this title real quick
I'm gonna read you out this title
Hi, oh perfect. Hi hi rage. Oh, it's such a so good to see you
So good to see you. I'm gonna look at your channel now
You don't have anything god damn it
um
x x n 4 r u 1 0
x s
4 s u k 3 mind you that's supposed to be xx naruto x sasuke
x x x
b
1 4 z
3 d x
I think that says blaze
blazed
j u
t 5 u 5
c 0
This is really hard to do because my mind is like reading it as the letters in the leapspeak
p 3 d x x
naruto xasuke blaze jutsu scoped
I want to see this hard at it
Oh
They're fighting
Not there by all
Oh sakura's crying. Oh this edit goes hard not gonna lie
Oh, they're always there for each other
This makes me
This would have gone so hard on tiktok if tiktok was around back then holy shit
Oh sponsor. Hello. Let's look at your channel
The king of 50 50s
I
Don't like the ai voice
This is a is this a genshin edit
Is this a genshin edit
I
I don't know
I did like the naruto and sasuke one more I will say I'm sorry
If it's not synced to suicide bars existination is it really a naruto edit?
Yeah, I'm just uh, I was playing black myth mukong and it keeps running like shit because I have a really crappy computer
And so now I'm just stalking everybody's channels that decides to speak so
Yep. Oh, is this the original one? This is the original account go
MCC guide halo 3 warthog launch an elephant bomb
I can't why can't I click on the video? Hello? Okay
I
Just finally works best for all the wata though
I feel like I'm listening to elden ring
Thing to like help me find scottetry fragments except a tailo
And you're not european
It froze
Oh
Doesn't show the menu so it just freezes
You should have just cut that out bro
You can't let them know don't worry
I I I only listen back to my own stream so I can see if the mic quality was good. Otherwise. I can't stand my voice
Oh, hi, even if you retract your message, I can still find you
I
Streamed this one year ago wink winks 10 live ps4 broadcasts
I'm not playing what is this dark souls you got some chat replay
I like how you're just resting at the the bonfire for the first 30 seconds
Literally for the first okay, sorry the first 24 seconds
No dialogue
Just vibes
Just dark souls
Bro wait hold on I feel like you have more stuff. Let me look at it. Let me go back
Uh
Paladins lienne casual. Yeah, you are filthy casual
I've never played paladins. I didn't realize that
Overwatch doesn't paladins come up before
Overwatch here to come out afterwards. I can't remember
It's just like Overwatch and Fortnite had a child
Why don't you talk in your videos? I don't know what's happening do some voice over his brother
All right, you're next
Dom of D&D hate love
Oh music
Oh, I didn't mean to make a full screen
Not the aerial font
Oh
Have a mic on the rocket like Kim Jong, oh my god, brother
Wait, wait, wait, wait
You have cotton cotton tail
Reacting to you sampling her hold on
Okay
You kind of do have the M&M sound I won't lie
Because you sampled her screams. That's so funny
That's that's pretty neat
Different rabbit girl is cheating. Well, he's not even he doesn't he's not membered. He doesn't have his oh she marked my oh she marks in his name
He's just a gray brother. So I'm not hating
I'm not gonna hate on a gray who who who doesn't have my oh she marks
Or if they have my jenemates oh she marks, that's fine
You're just a gray
Maybe you're gay
It's okay
I'll welcome you any ways to stream. Hi. What's up? My name is she be caught in bomb. I hope you're enjoying yourself
Oh, hi
You're new
Your name is very weird. Let's take a look
Maren sass versus cyber dragons. Is this bakugan? Oh, no, it's it's yugioh. Why do you have fucking ads on your video?
I swear to god if nobody's saying anything in this game
Not a lick
Of dialogue. I can't watch yugioh gameplay with no dialogue
I'm yelling and it's hurting my throat
Do you have anything else?
Local legends
Polychrome tri stars rika versus math mech
What is this game?
What game is this?
Oh, it's more yugioh dual links
I'm not a I don't like yugioh. I'm sorry. Um, good good good good on you brother. Good on you
Oh, what's going on? Oh, that's so crazy. Welcome. Oh
What the fuck is your profile picture? It's one of those weird foxes
What's wrong with yugioh dual links
I
Couldn't tell
Didn't want to see him like a coward. I like that you spilled coward wrong
Let's take a peek then
Strani, I'm uh, I'm I'm watching everybody. I'm look. I'm going through everybody who speaks youtube channel and I'm just
Listening to everything winter of mavic. Let's take a peek
This is gorgeous this drone footage
Music is questionable
I don't know what the fuck kind of music is in the background, but very beautiful drone shots
Would definitely see this shit in national geographic
Nice transitions. Oh, I like, uh, I think my favorite timestamp is 255
That's nice
anyways
Yeah
Can't have anything in these chats. You're not safe for me
And now I'll do the same thing. No, then you'll just get flooded with tweets because I'll be like, oh if I post later
I'm just going to read all your tweets. Oh, hi boomie
What's that handsome? What are you coming over for? Hello? Would you like some pets?
Struggle if I real tears or donkey. Yeah, I'm like, why does this sound familiar?
I
Titty-titty-titty grab boomies titties, I bet I could milk you like a cow
He's staring at me like why are you doing this? I can't help it boomy your pouches humongous
He just ran away
Oh
Don't trust vealer knowing the main get out of here get out of here
I don't want if you if you are in a side account
You don't you why are you here?
Why don't you why don't you just watch on your main? Are you ashamed?
Are you ashamed of me?
Are you
Sub with your whole chest
You guys are ashamed to watch us and I can't I can't believe it. I can't believe it strawney strawney if you're still here. Uh, I I
They're they're embarrassed they're embarrassed about us
They're all embarrassed. Oh wait, you just got back from class. That's crazy. Let's look at your let's look at your channel
Got nothing except
except fucking mordecai
looking mortified
I
Can't believe it
Strawney I think we need to rebrand into a say so only corpo
Guys, it's you know, I'm I'm getting well. I'm not turning into a white woman. Hold on I'm
Hold on
I'm I'm now gonna be say so
I'm gonna wear proper clothing
And no one will tell me any different
Okay
My voice is really nasally right now because my throat hurt perfect. I have white hands
Don't worry about it. It's just the lighting
That's not can I
What the hell
Oh
There we go, okay, why is my head so far away from my body?
Can I
This is not what I wanted
No
Okay, you know what you go there. I go down here and then this goes down here
I'm say so. Oh my mole is kind of going crazy. I don't know what it's attached to
It's kind of it's still what is this thing attached to?
I
Guess it's oh whatever doesn't matter to me
My hands look discolored. Well, I'm putting up my fists to fight you
Moles on my ear layer. Oh, yeah, you're right. It was
Strony, Strony, uh, we need to rebrand. I think we should we're no longer an avtuber corpo
We are now say so girly pops
We're youtube can't do anything. It's totally ogre
um
I think I think I think it's time to call it. I think we got to call ourselves
V
V via say so
You know
Uh, I'm sorry guys v not sucky. I was thinking I was gonna say be sucky, but I'm like wait, how does that fit into that?
Um, I'm dooming it's over
I'm the shadow ceo. Yeah, I am the shadow ceo. It's me guys
It's me v and w virtual and wholesome
We are adjacent to v and u
Why is why is wholesome?
Oh, I thought you did it with an h
We're now v not sucky
You can't call her the shadows brother
No, you needed you we needed you two v's for that
It'd have to be like this it'd have to be like
Oh
Why did I capitalize it? I can't type
You know, yeah
Whole sun why can't you spell for anything?
Yeah, we're now v wholesome
And you said we spell it like that
v alone
Wholesome content only v you're supposed to be writing shorts to keep getting this
I'm so fun
Mommy thinks I'm fun
v I thought that said horses
Um, hold on. Let me take off my white body. Oh
Oh
But yeah, I'm wholesome. Oh my mole's gone. Oh, I'm gone. Oh look at my hair physics
Ah
Get me out of this fucking blender
Okay
Wait, what shorts are you writing?
I'm about to fight our shorts people
I want more shorts. Tell them to edit my shorts faster. I'm coming for them and not in the fun way
ASMR ones, oh cool
Wait, hold on. Let me grab a p
I want to grab a p and g of straw knee and just have her with me in my room
Okay
Yeah, I'll do that
I'll do I'll do that photo set
Do I have any done
That would be great if I had some shorts that were finished. Oh, so I can upload some what am I doing?
Oh, yeah, I was gonna grab a p and g of you so I can
Have you with me in spirit? Uh should be under artworks and then
If I scroll nope, that's a zero his ass
Keep scrolling
Keep scrolling. Why are there where the full body? There's no full body p and g's
I thought we had full body p and g's of us. Well, I can have your head at least so
Perfect
Oh, lovely now actually let me do this I can't do that right now
I
Perfect
Nothing can keep
So I can just pretend hold on I can pretend no that looks wrong
I just pretend she's right. Oh wait. No, I you know what I can probably do. I can probably just give you a body myself
Hold on. Let me give you. Oh, you know what? This will be cute if I give you, uh, those hands. I just had
Where are they where'd those hands go? Here we go. Let's do these ones
Oh strong he's about to be so cute. Wait, can I?
Oh
What the hell oh look at look at this
Look at that
Oh, look at somebody take a script. Hold on. Let me just I'll get out of the way
My freckles are gone. You guys can take a picture
You guys can take a picture of that
For your own for your own needs
Look at that. Doesn't she look so cute? She's watching the reeflings piss. Yeah
Isn't that nice
I spy with my little eye a new person that I can creep on. Let me just go to your channel
Lotas dray her off dare not to shill feel
Uh, this is in german
I think whoa
Driving fast cars is 14 years ago
Oh my god, you almost drove into the guard rail
Brother what car are you driving? What's that? I can't tell
Oh, you're driving a lotus. That's why you're driving. Jesus cool
Cut cut cut kawaii. Okay. I'm back
So now I'm going to be oh, I made strani too big and then I'm gonna make myself bigger because I'm taller than strani
And then I'll give myself some hands and then we can look so cute together
If I could find the hands
Oh, wait, I have an idea. I have I have an idea. Hold on. Let me do this hand asset
I have an idea
Wait, oh no, they're gonna be fucking tan. So it's gonna not be right. God damn it
I was gonna I was gonna give strani some knees
Strani got some tan knees
Hold on hold on
I don't know how I come up with this shit. Anyways, uh, so strani will be with me in here in spirit for the remainder of the stream
Let me let me turn the desktop audio back on hold on and if you guys don't know I was just fucking around with the stuff off
Nope, that's twitter
That's twitter
You
No, okay, you guys did it cool
Imagine a raid night. What do you mean people would come in and be like, oh strani's here, too. I'd be like
Hello. No, that was like I see
I
Stares at you scottishly
Hello, everybody. I am strani kittles. I am your favorite scottish vtuber
I can I can bring an ic2 hold on I can I can have ic show up
I'm really bummed because me I see it in me. We're gonna have a address to impress collab
Why didn't I do this sooner? Why didn't I load them in as
Assets sooner. I don't understand why I didn't do that
Oh, this is perfect
And now I have ic. Oh my god. She's a little baby between hold on
We look like we look like a lesbian couple with our child. Let me let me give her a binky
Do I not have a binky?
Is it called pacifier? I know I have a fucking passi
Oh
What the hell? Why isn't it in here?
Oh, here it is
Perfect
For our little our little child
It's stuck to my hair, but that's fine, but it looks like she's talking
The child looks different. She takes after her mother. I don't know what to tell you
I don't know what to tell you
Uh, I want to give
Oh
I can essentially just make a whole family photo right now. Hold on
Uh, let's grab. Let's grab
Let's grab emi
I don't know why this is the picture we have of her, but okay
Let's grab everybody else is like normal looking and then like emi's face is the only one that doesn't look normal
Save mercy and then a zura looking looking lovely
With her little I love is there a smile on her model. It's so cute. Uh, okay
I'm making a family photo
The pacifier is moving because it's connected to my hair
Um, okay, so let me grab let's do a zura in the back
What?
Did it not save?
Hello
Downloads
Where's the reasons
It should be under a zero, okay, it is under a zero ahead
I don't know why because it does it automatically in alphabetical order and I'm like why isn't a zura's head there
Why isn't her head there? What if I just like refresh it?
I see you want I'm gonna stick you guys all to me, you know, I see is next to me
and
I'm trying I can't get a zura's head guys. Oh, there there it is
Um, hold on a zura. I'm sorry. I need to put you behind us
Uh, where where does her go again her lake? Thank you disappearing. Okay. I'm gonna put you
There we go. Oh my god
Oh
Wait, hold on the thing is
Move us down
I'm making a fan. This is like a Brady Bunch family photo. I'm actually really happy right now. Like
I mean, I see
Okay, let's make
Just draw me a little bit closer
There we go, and there we go a zura
And then hold on let me find a body for a zura
Um
Her skin tone is a little bit different from mine, but that's fine
Let's
All give her she make her into a noodle that'd be funny
I can't give her the
Oh
I was gonna give her the milk body because that fits her honestly. She should I could probably
Get that for her
She would look really good with that asset. Okay, let's do my head
I can't oh fuck I can't grab it
That works that works. Oh fuck it's stuck to me. It's fine. It's stuck to me, but it's fine
And I'll just
Move it up the fucking binky
I have to stick it I see to my I see doesn't have a freaking body
Um, okay, let's get let's get mercy and then let me know we'll save the best for last
Oh my god, okay, sorry
I accidentally put made mercy too big and I didn't put her behind this
Okay
She's just looming actually I might have I might have mercy and
Hold on because this is like
I'm trying to make a family portrait
That was properly sized. I'm gonna put mercy on the other side of stronti
Look I see
I might give I see a noodle body
Can I
I didn't mean to move. Sorry body down. I just want to move
I
Wait, maybe I could put mercy right above stronti
This doesn't make sense because of our heights, but it's fine. Um, let's try it again
I just make mercy just like creeping
I don't know. I don't know where to put mercy
I don't know what if I
Do
That looks good. Yeah
You can hang out there mercy and then let me grab and then Emmys is funny because like you can see
All of us are like they're all like normal faced and then there's emmy
I love my jet me so much
Okay
I feel like I need to move all of us over
I
I'll give emmy a body
Let me give emmy a body. I'll give her the body that I use sometimes
Let's do
Oh
Well, she's gonna be a little what if I actually if I
Yeah, if I do that
The hook is the hood. Okay, it's that one
Game it I I need it. Oh freak. Everything's attached to me
Oh wait, I need to
Oh
Okay, I need to click everything
Making this family portrait is hard
Okay, and then I need to sorry emmy. I need to throw you away for just a split second. Um, and then let me
Grab that body I have to do the body first or I can make emmy a nun
For her nun era, no, I'll I'll give her just a cute body
Uh, we gotta make that four
E
And then
She's not she's not you guys you they won't oh what the hell why is it look
Why is it like darker? Um
Because I'm gonna have her little hands up so you won't be able to it'll just look like a shadow
Oh, no, actually I didn't mean to get rid of that
I heard my freckles
It just like flew off into oblivion
As there is using the bat in the background, I don't know if you guys can tell
Okay
Oh
There we go
I need to like stay still
Quick take the picture
I
Take the screenshot
Wait, I should probably give mercy about I can't tell it kind of looks like she has like a turtleneck on but
I see losing such a cute baby
This is what morning looks like what do you mean give her a noodle neck
Um
I just have a really bad idea
Yeah, I'll do it after I'll do it
Why didn't I do that before oh my god
Where the heck is the tail?
Wait, what if I do this I give her a very small body
If I take
Oh, I can't even grab it. Oh here it is if I take and rotate it
Amy come back with your head
Uh
Amy's head is too far away. I'm just gonna make myself. Oh
No, she's on a straight jacket she could be
Actually, no, I think I deleted this. I had a straight jacket PNG
Yeah, good family photo, right, right
All right, I just got a really funny idea
Hello
Uh
Wait, no, don't don't look actually I don't want you to look don't look at me
Where is it
Why did I think of this before it's gonna look so goofy
Let me just rotate that
Wait, no, I need to put it behind I need to put it behind or was it I forget what the name of it was. Oh, there it is
I hope you guys will still love me this way
Oh
Food dispenser my beloved
I don't look like I'm riding a horse
Uh taking a stroll
I look like I'm naked
Oh, I look like a I look like a rat dog
You like my hair
Yeah
Out of fingers. Oh man, if I get like a little tech deck and be like
Wait, hold on got you
Fuck I'll have to edit this photo
Uh, excuse me
Skateboard
Download
You want me to fucking pay for a PNG brother
You know what? Fuck it. I'm just gonna rip the
this image
and then just
Keep the black the the background
Why don't I say oh god, that is a weird file name. Okay, it should be at the very top there we go
Oh wow it actually saved us
It saved us a PNG. I didn't think I would
Wait, wait, I need I need like Mercy's background music. I need Mercy's I need Mercy's BGM. Hold on
Uh
I'm just gonna click on any video and just
Do her opening
Oh, that just scared me. Nope. That's not her life
I'm
Studying with you at magic school ASMR
Mercy has really good ASMRs. Uh, let's see this
This is an ad
I got really confused because I'm like, she's not streaming. Why is the chat going? It's because it's the way to play
Let's go
Oh
Wait, hold on you make myself smaller
Freaking nolly bro, why am I suddenly Australian?
I
Made myself smaller
I can't
I
Can't
I'm literally
Okay
I
Accidentally land on the fireplace
Wow
I
Wait, I want to ramp
This will do
It's funny because Mercy's gonna start talking at any moment now. I need to restart her video
I'm starting the half pipe event ladies and gentlemen hold on
Oh
What did it save as
Perfect, I know this is gonna cover me
Oh, please hold
I
Wait, what is this pink thing on me? What is that?
What is why did I notice? What is what is that?
Is that my cushion? Is that the shading for
Why that's the
Shade
Those are my legs it's my leg shadow why is it why is it there?
Oh
Why does that not show up
Over here, but it shows up on there. I don't see any
Shade difference station doesn't turn anything pink
Because it's like whatever. Wow. It looks like I'm hitting a combo
So I'm so small help
Sorry, this takes a while to do
I
Combo hold on
Combo
I
Like my moves
So
Radical
What kicks in
I
Try to watch this mom mom watch watch
Excellent
I
Is this so fun
Smoking sexy style
Nice combo
Oh
Nice cock
What just popped up on my screen
Oh my god, why is Microsoft Edge opening?
Nice pussy
Totally tubular
Oh
Aren't you guys are you guys happy you're
Call me she be hawk hawk toa if you don't hawk to a I don't talk to a
Stick the landing
Incredible
Thanks for the updated membership
Is
Okay, okay, I think I'm done I'm done. I swear
Well
That's another average she be stream
Oh
I'm gonna I'm gonna go feed fia. She's staring at me
Like why are you crying?
I hope you enjoyed
You
Hold up
In sanity
Oh
It's mercy mercy showing up I had to close this down
It's just funny it doesn't show up in the background even if it doesn't matter if it's why I should still be able to see it
That's so weird
I can't stop crying from laughter
I mean I want a better ramp
I want to wait
Hold on
We're not done yet
This is this is my time. This is my time. It's my time
I just I needed a better ramp
Wait, where is it
It didn't download properly
What the fuck is the jiffy file? Okay, whatever. Never mind
I almost threw up in my mouth. I'll do
I found a better ramp, but I can't use it. It's not the right
It's not the right thing
um
so
Sorry, I had to get that out of my system. Oh, is there anything else that you guys want me to say in my voice?
What the fuck
What the fuck anymore I go
Wait, jason, amazing
Amazing
Oh
Super cool
He thought I said something else what
Five nights at sheepie
Look at my fucking weight
Wait
Great
I
Okay, I have to find the ramp
No, I don't want it to be stuck to me
No, it's stuck to me
Not like this
Not if I just stuck to my blinking
Oh
Help
Help me
Raina help me
Oh
Wait, I need mercies to stop BGM again. I need mercies BGM again
I need to be a little bit smaller
So
Delicious
Kill yourself
I
Tasty
Oh
Scrubbed the leopards
I
Life has no meaning
Wait
Poggers
You are the father
I
Can't even think of anything to say
Because I'm laughing so hard
Oh wait, wait, wait
Shhh
Glorp that giggle stick
Yeah, you tell him boomy
Let's dun dun dun dun dun duel
Okay, okay now I'm done
Now I am now I'm complete
Oh my god
So
I don't know why your BGM reminds me of Coldly Yoko's
Watch me get like claimed for using mercies BGM somehow. Oh, uh, I hope you guys
Enjoyed
I hope you guys enjoy
Yeah, yeah, how are you doing? Hi, she's like mother
I need to probably take a shower before I go to bed
I
I'm happy you guys stick to
Oh wait
Keep being radical too
Okay, wait, I should have stuck this on my hand better
It looks like I have a boss
Why am I like
I remember lesbians wet dream am I this is what the girls want
It's a girl all the bad guys want
It's the girl all the bad guys want
Oh
I'm delirious
All right, let's find somebody to raid
Oh
You know what we're gonna raid chiaki because she's doing scott pilgrim versus the world
And I don't know why but I feel like that fits
You can say gnarly raid
I muted myself radical raid. There you go
Okay, here I'm gonna I'll sit in the middle so you guys can get your pictures
Wait, I need to take my own screenshot
I
I'm seeing this as I'm crying
Wait, wait, wait
Wait, what the fuck is my bed? I just have a ball from the back
How do you take another screenshot?
Save as
Please someone stop me
This is a stinky
I
Thumb is the peepee
Oh
Wait, hold on
I just just one more things
Oh wait, wait, hold on hold
Wait, wait, no, don't look
Don't look
And then
You
Guys I need I need I need I need
I need an idea for the the shout out thing like the
Dual noise, please help somebody come up with something and then I'll reveal myself
I'm trying to calm down. I wish I had my heart rate
Wait, wait, I got you
Hey
Clamelia
Wait, wait, I have another idea.
I need to get this off of me.
Deep breath, sheepy, deep breath, deep breath, sheepy.
Oh fuck, it's still attached.
No, let go.
I can't handle the fever.
Why is it still attached to me?
Stop, we'll get on the touch, okay.
Pick a number one through five.
Actually wait, no, never mind.
Wait, I need to, maybe if I do this,
I can make myself small enough.
No, it's hard.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
It insists.
I can't move her.
My head is like a small floating dot.
You can see this is my head.
I was trying to like stick myself to it.
But it wasn't working.
Wait, will it work now?
No, it won't.
Hey, you can't see me if I go into her hair.
I'm like a little, I'm like a little louse.
She's looking at me.
Am I going to get in trouble for this?
It's even more naked than I am.
No, no, I didn't want to load it as fucking live duty.
No.
Am I over tired or what?
Anyways, have a great time.
It'll be a radical raid.
Hold on, let me make sure this person is still streaming.
Oh my God, they're probably not.
Never mind.
Or maybe they're going to keep going.
You know what, I'm going to go to the actual,
I'm going to go, you know what, I'm too tired to do that.
I was going to go to the stream.
She started streaming at seven.
It should be fine.
Okay.
All right.
I'm stinky, you're stinky.
We're all stinky together today.
I'm going to go take a shower and cry and debate my,
and wonder why I am the way I am.
I didn't say sticky.
I said stinky.
Why are you stinky?
Okay.
What is free age, I mean?
There's a G now.
Why are you laughing at G?
I'm kind of running down my vagina.
All right, I'm leaving.
Goodbye.